so that's Ukrainian president Guy what's
his name zielinski he called for NATO to
engage in preemptive strikes against
Russia to show them before not after
what happens if you use nuclear weapons
and then everybody was like whoa that's
a little overboard and Russia was like
yo that's a little overboard and then he
comes out he's like no no I meant to say
sanctions impose sanctions
no because we've already been told that
if Russia uses nuclear weapons it will
be full-scale conventional Warfare from
NATO so that's not what would happen
sanctions no no zolenski I think was
actually saying it's time for NATO to
strike Russia because he wants War he
wants World War III I guess he's saying
if I'm going down I'm taking you with me
there have already been a bunch of
Russian officials uh a bunch a couple
that have called on Russia to start
using low-yield nuclear weapons so
that'll be fun it's very important
stories today Twitter rolled out the
edit button and I'm having a whole lot
of fun on Twitter just editing away and
the other really big news ladies and
gentlemen
Velma
not only is she gay she's actually black
and Shaggy his real name it's Norville
he's black too you think I'm kidding I
I'm not kidding I mean this is like they
just released this I guess and now Velma
and Shaggy are both black and uh I guess
and they're making a point about how
they're gonna start changing things
because the classics don't work or
whatever but you know I think this is an
interesting culture War story so we'll
talk about that before we get started
head over to timcast.com and become a
member to support our work directly as a
member you get access to the uncensored
after Show members only Monday through
Thursday at 11 PM and you'll also get
access to shows like cast Castle Vlog
Tales from the inverted World Plus we've
got a bunch of other stuff like The
Green Room show behind the scenes
downstairs in our green room with all
our fun guests and you'll be supporting
our journalists directly because they're
only working because you guys are
members so don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
share this show with your friends
joining us tonight to talk about all of
this news and more is Joel Berry
hi who are you yeah what are you doing
here uh yeah uh I am the managing editor
of the Babylon bee and I suppose yeah
toward me okay all right yeah that's
better yeah see as you can tell I've
done this many times
um yeah uh me and Kyle Mann uh run the
Babylon B
um we also wrote the book uh The Babylon
bee guide to democracy which just came
out
um and uh you can follow me on Twitter
at Joel W Barry all right well thanks
for joining us it's gonna be fun we got
Luke Rutkowski good to see my fellow
people of color getting some uh some
some time finally on Scooby-Doo the
power's with us anyway the the shirt
that I'm wearing today actually I I made
almost uh a year ago specifically with
um you know uh saying that uh at least
we get a pizza party before World War
Three it's it's uh very topical right
now you could get it on
thebestpoliticalshirts.com and of course
it shows Joe Biden uh chomping away on
some pizza so yeah because you get the
shirt I'm here thank you so much for
having me what's up everybody Ian
crossing over here and yes Cass Castle
did go live yesterday the best episode
yet Civil War the culmination of a
four-part series I hope you have had a
chance to see it I think some people
with feedback said that it was uh it was
lagging or there was buffering issues so
we're working on that it might be a
browser thing try a different browser
try clearing your cache and maybe we'll
talk about Hunter Biden today because uh
Federal agency chargeable offense fences
with tax expenses I think if we do get
into it well we'll save it for the show
and uh what's going on yeah I'm over
here as well thank you guys for having
me of course I'm pushing buttons in the
corner
um Tim got the ability to edit tweets
he's been having a blast with that go
check out this Twitter for sure let's
get into it it just I just did one last
edit Joe Joe Biden is a bad president
and it just gave me a warning it was
like this is your last edit stop five
minutes total I guess is that five no I
think it's yeah it's five edits okay so
it started with Joe Biden as a bad
president then Joe Biden is a good
President Joe Biden is a child sniffer
Joe Biden is responsible for high gas
prices retweet this if you think the
noble rooster is the greatest of God's
creations after people of course and
then finally back to Joe Biden is a bad
president and then when you try to edit
it again it said please stop or did it
did it stop it stop gosh uh you can't do
it anymore okay you can no longer edit
full circle five edits in 30 minutes
that's the rule all right ladies and
gentlemen here's the news I hope you're
sitting down for this one zelenski calls
for preemptive strikes from NATO to keep
Russia from using nukes
okay whatever man
zelinski says it's time for world war
three everyone should burn in a reign of
nuclear Hellfire he didn't really say
that but he may have what may as well
have said that Vladimir zielinski called
on NATO to conduct preemptive strikes
against Russian targets to prevent their
use of nuclear weapons in Ukraine which
literally would do the opposite I okay
that that's it I kind of feel like he's
actually just saying you know it's the
waiting I can't stand just burn it all
to the ground because no one no saying
rational person thinks a preemptive
strike against Russia would result in
anything other than them launching
nuclear weapons so I think this is
zielinski was throwing like people and
like I think he shut down
um TV stations three the three largest
TV stations in Ukraine I think you had
them shut down because they were and not
against them and political parties as
well that were against him yeah he's not
a good guy he's maybe was an actor so
he's got some Charisma but I don't think
he's like a benevolent president during
the time of War all the rules are out of
the window so you know we have to
understand we're not fighting for
democracy here this is not a democracy
but he shut those TV stations down
before any Russian I believe it was
during the I believe it was because of
of the war and the emergency powers that
the government got but again all rules
everything's off the table once there's
a war and that's how he's treating the
situation his statements today I mean
he's trying to you know walk them back
as much as he can he's trying to say
that he wanted to really call for
preemptive sanctions but there's a big
distinction between preemptive strikes
and preemptive sanctions and he was
specifically talking to an Australian
Think Tank the lowly institution and
these are Big statements the Russians
are coming out and saying well these
statements risk another world war and
and these are very dangerous statements
and this is the trajectory that we are
on unless there's some actual
de-escalation detonte and some real
civil conversations that could actually
pull us away from this lunacy you mean
like Elon Musk yes at least he's trying
his proposal wasn't perfect but at least
he tried at least he started the
conversation and now lunatic Lindsey
Graham the chicken hawk that he is is
saying that he's going to be taken away
his uh his tax credits which he never
got for his Tesla company he never even
had someone's gotta try someone's got to
try to de-escalate I I guess I also
wonder like why is he asking why is he
asking NATO to do a preemptive strike so
let's get like 50 billion dollars worth
of weapons why why is he doing it there
are three Democrats who have now
publicly stated that the greatest
National Security objective for the
United States is to defeat Russia in
Ukraine they came out and said it you
know we're at war with Russia they're
just playing this game it's not for
Russia's benefit Russia knows we're at
war with them it's because it's illegal
because what they're doing violates the
Constitution they did not get
Congressional approval for this so
they're going to dance around like you
know you know people ask you've got
you've got U.S Personnel veterans on the
ground in Ukraine we now have
confirmation from The Intercept that U.S
boots are actually doing Special
Operations on the ground at what point
are we just like okay dudes we get it
you declared war on Russia
but that's the game Vladimir Putin knows
full well what NATO and the US are doing
there
they're lying saying it's just veterans
being supplied and trained by us and
then delivering weapons and training to
the ukrainians there only was no saying
that is because they're not legally
allowed to do it and they did so
criminals criminals in the in the
government
yeah that never happened before uh musk
made another statement today when he was
attacked by the Kiev post he said uh
look I love Ukraine but not World War
III and I think that's the sentiment for
the majority of people right now looking
at this situation rationally as we're
not really you know this conversation
it's it's shared about online but when
we look at the mainline coverage this is
not really talked about as much as
significantly the corporate media right
now is focusing on two Russians that
swam to Alaska to avoid the mobilization
that seems to be that the biggest kind
of story that you see on the main
headline television networks but you
don't really hear about the dangerous
implications you don't really hear
anti-war voices you don't really hear
anything contrary other than we need War
let's play chicken nuclear war because
it's fun somehow and that's that's
insane for the record they uh zielinski
shut down three TV stations in February
of 21 2021 a year before Putin invaded
and they were like pro-russia according
to him was like oh it's Russian so
they've really been at like a pseudo
Wharf since 2014 I mean since Putin
Annex Crimea that was pretty overt you
guys know that the U.S had an office of
censorship during World War II yeah yeah
silence accelerates victory was their
slogan The Motto I guess oh we played
Japanese and internment camps too I mean
yeah that's right you know as a part of
the world well information is key and
you know many times there was
accusations against Germans there was
accusations against Japanese citizens
that were providing allegedly
information to the enemy and the United
States took it as far as to literally
set up camps for Japanese people to be
interned in which was a step too far and
I think you know during these situations
during emergency situations we should
always be careful not to take a step too
far and we have done it time and time
again I'm watching this video or I have
been of uh like volunteers on the ground
in Ukraine American guy goes over with a
helmet cam and he's recording it as he's
running around fighting like they're in
combat and they don't know who they're
fighting they don't know where the enemy
is they're just being told by a squad
leader who's like a french guy or like
some Ukrainian dude they got a
friendship so they just go place they
wait and then they're like if someone
tells them speaking of information being
important if someone says that's the
enemy fire they'll just start shooting
they don't know yep yeah how many how
many uh Ukrainian citizens you think
joined with the Russians something that
they don't talk about in Western media
but but of course they did especially in
the East they probably said you know
we're with you know Russia on this one
otherwise I mean they wouldn't have it's
just the output I'll leave it at that my
question and the reason I bring that up
is do you believe the Western media that
Ukraine is winning
this is a I think a topic worth
discussing because we might see opposing
viewpoints on this as we were kind of
talking about this subject before the
show there's there's a lot of
circumstantial evidence there's there's
the understanding that there's a lot of
propaganda a lot of disinformation but
we also have to understand that the
ukrainians were practicing and drilling
for this ever since 2014 on their
territory they have the latest
technology they have night vision they
have thermal they have satellite
technology they have GPS coordinated uh
weapon systems they have training from
CIA covert Ops Special Forces soldiers
that were there since 2014 setting up
the groundwork for this Invasion as the
U.S corporate media was literally
cheering on and setting the groundwork
to make everyone hate Russia so this has
been in the works for a very long time
and I do believe
from just my initial perspectives from
what I've seen and I know people are
going to attack me I got attacked last
week because I said the ukrainians are
going to take the city of Lyman the
ukrainians did take the city of Lyman
but from my perspective looking at the
telegram channels seeing footage from
the Russians and the ukrainians it does
seem especially right now that the
ukrainians are getting back a lot of the
territory and are having some
significant victories against what looks
like a disorganized force with the
Russians that's my perspective in my
opinion and I could be wrong and I know
I'm going to get you know for it I don't
believe the propaganda but it's also not
the ukrainians it's NATO NATO is winning
back these cities
Russia's not fully engaged as far as I
can tell from what I've heard I mean
they have not committed their entire
military he just raised another 300 000
people uh drafted I think they drafted
mobilization well in the mobilization
there's also a secret paragraph that
hasn't been released to the general
public uh but but also Russia is facing
stiff declines in their population just
like the majority of the Western World
Taiwan uh the ministry of Defense
actually came out today and also said
that they have a huge problem because of
the low birth rate they're not going to
have anyone to join the military soon uh
so Russia is also facing a very similar
problem
um and and you know how many people are
fleeing that's that's contested there's
a lot of disinformation there's a lot of
propaganda and a lot of it is just
censored centered around Russia bad uh
the war they're losing at 100 that's not
the 100 Truth uh out of the situation
but again we're in a war the reporting
has been just propaganda and that's
exactly what it is from now on well do
you think that it's possible that the
fact that Putin is talking about nuclear
weapons is a sign that maybe he is
losing yeah
I think that's a better indication to me
than anything coming out of the media
just I don't know if he'd be talking
like that if if losing losing though to
the degree that he's engaged I mean the
question is has has Russia utilized all
of their their forces to the maximum
capability obviously no because they
have nukes and then the question is okay
well aside from nukes then are they
using their Ground Forces well no they
just mobilized another 300 000 they
could certainly conscript more people so
they've not even maximized in terms of
ground troops and then it's
if they really wanted to to declare
full-scale war I mean they don't even
have to use icbms they have our there's
a bunch of weapons they could and
haven't used there was video going out
of them dropping incendiary bombs on a
city why have they not done that in
larger numbers on other cities because
it looks like Russia is actually
restrained right now it looks like
there's a lot of supply shortages it
looks like a lot of their main routes
have been met with a lot of resistance
and there's also a lot of video footage
showing you know Russians fighting with
you know regular red book bags fighting
with no uh armor at all fighting with
old equipment so again how much of how
much of that is propaganda how much of
it is real but I've seen similar reports
and similar videos from uh you know the
Russian side showing them fighting
having victories but but still a lot of
them are under equipped a lot of them
don't have any body armor at all I think
there was an expectation that they would
move in from the East and that the
people in Ukraine would open their arms
and be like kind of like what happened
in Crimea be like well elf thank you now
we're we're liberated we're back as part
of Russia we used to you know they were
they used to be part of Russia before
the Soviet Union was split up at all of
Ukraine and but they he that it was
underestimated the amount of
psychological propaganda that have been
proliferated in Ukraine and and pro-west
pro liberal economic order and there was
just massive psychological resistance
they you know everyone a lot of people
thought zelinski was going to flee as
soon as the invasion was announced but
he was like no I'm staying probably
because psychologically he was prepared
because of all this NATO influence but
also Russia hasn't fully declared it as
a war they're describing it as a limited
Military operation uh so so we have to
understand it attacks on the
infrastructure weren't made by the
Russians the Russians could take out the
electricity the power the water and a
lot of other uh especially with their
control of of the the nuclear facility
inside of Ukraine they haven't done that
yet so I think they're still holding
back some cards that will make a greater
impact on this conflict not just nuclear
warheads but uh a declaration of a full
all-out War let me jump to these stories
here the first from Daily Mail quote use
low-yield nuclear weapons Russia
appointed official inkerson calls for
tough action from Moscow and urges the
country defense minister Sergey shoigu
to shoot himself amid frustration at
Ukrainian fight back we also have this
story from Reuters catarov says Russia
should use low-yield nuclear weapon so
uh they're outright saying use the nukes
this is interesting because I feel like
nuclear war man if there's anything that
would happen that would make a great
reset happen it would be nuclear bombs
dropping but the question is
is this you know what's happening in
Ukraine going to affect the entire
planet or is it going to stay Regional
is it going to become something that
forces the West to get involved
or does Ukraine just get you know win or
lose I don't know when nukes come into
play I don't see how the whole world
doesn't get involved I mean I guess one
thing that does make me nervous is
where's China and all this when the
nukes start flying what does China do
well sit back and laugh well yeah they
could I guess and just watch us commit
suicide Annex a huge part of Eastern
Russia yeah you know watch out for that
well Kissinger had some interesting
comments about China and how they're
looking at everything that's happening
right now we also have to understand
that Ukraine and China were very big
trading partners and there's a lot of
economic interests that the Chinese have
inside of Ukraine so this could be one
reason why they kind of stepped back a
little bit but according to Henry
Kissinger the Chinese gave the Russians
a blank check when it came to
um this this conflict right now I'm not
really seeing it uh but I I think it's
it's in their interest for themselves to
be like you know what we're just going
to take a step back as YouTube guys beat
each other up and we're gonna rise as as
a potential superpower or try to rise as
a potential superpower well that's the
Art of War right never on your up your
enemies when they're destroying each
other yes and there's been a lot of
historical tensions between Russia and
China China they have started to work
closer together especially with the
United States becoming more aggressive
against both of them they started to
share a lot of military Secrets they
started to build a lot of uh military
infrastructure together uh but but
historically they've been at odds even
when it comes to specific territory that
they were were threatening each other
with just a few decades ago
The Intercept report that I saw earlier
I think uh Michael Tracy was tweeting
about it I mean that was just a kick in
the balls that the U.S is operating
officially U.S Special Operations and
intelligence are operating in Ukraine so
like that's it they they this is the
game they play the US and NATO they
didn't come out outright and say we're
going to engage in war with Russia they
they dropped news periodically first it
was like well some people volunteered
just what happens to their Americans
then it's well we're giving weapons to
you know Poland and it's being delivered
to Ukraine that's not us and then the
U.S Intel U.S intelligence helped
Ukraine blow up the Russian Black Sea
Fleet Flagship and then said oh well we
didn't tell them to do that
now the U.S is saying well yeah we we do
have special operations on the ground
that are ours and our intelligence has
been operating there I'm gonna tell you
this they're they're blaming Ukraine for
the assassination of uh Dugan's daughter
yeah
how long give it a week two weeks a
month before they're like oh yeah we
actually ordered that or at first
they're going to say we gave them the
information on where Dugan would be but
we didn't know that would happen and
then a month that's gonna be like yeah
it was us so so basically what the
United States is doing is handing
someone a gun and saying we're going to
point it exactly where you're going to
kill this opponent and the only thing
they're they're not doing is pulling the
trigger that's not sure anymore
but some people as as you know you would
argue they're doing even more than just
pulling the trigger
deniability no no here's what it is all
right all right so Joel you're you're
fighting with your neighbor and so I'm
like all right here's what we're gonna
do I'm gonna give you this uh glass
bottle all right now you're gonna you
got you got that but uh but you know
what uh actually Luke used to work for
me Luke you go do it that's basically
what it is yeah it starts with people
are like they used to be soldiers for
this Army but now it's just their choice
to go there right right right and they
and then they have weapons that get
supplied by NATO and then eventually
they're just like yeah they're paying us
so yeah we're involved at what point
does everyone figure out that just you
know when do we eliminate the middleman
and just go direct at each other I
imagine I'm saying you know look just
I mean like if Joe Biden wants my
respect he'll come out and be like my
fellow Americans of course we're at war
with Russia what he's stupid you don't
think U.S boots on the ground funding
supplies intelligence and War you think
that does not imply that we are fighting
right we're thinking yeah but these you
know I I think what you get from Twitter
and from the media is you can really see
these like psychotic fascist journalists
will say whatever to keep regular people
trapped in the dark right they'll call
you fake news they'll lie they'll push
conspiracy theories and then claim it's
you doing that projection is the only
thing they have and the best part is
they accuse everyone else of projecting
when it's quite literally then projected
yeah they're the fascists supporting the
machine and supporting the war now we're
facing the prospect of uh getting hit by
a nuke so I guess you know for uh for
you guys have you guys bought your
potassium iodide yet I had mine for many
years ago as I was warning about this on
my YouTube channel saying hey we're
headed towards a conflict with Russia
like like 10 years ago I was making
videos about this I was like
geopolitically everything's aligning
everything's shaping up as of course
this is not the first proxy war that
happened between the East and the West
we look at Syria we look at Libya we
look at Afghanistan in the 1980s the
United States and the Russians have
always been at odds with each other
always financing the enemy of the enemy
and this is nothing new but now I think
we have really escalated it to a
dangerous situation that implicates
everyone in it including everyone that's
not even fighting innocent human beings
are being affected by this in more ways
than one not just financially but what
about what about other countries I mean
turkey military Power Nuclear superpower
they're a Russian neighbor they I mean
Russia they're a NATO member yeah and
they're in NATO which is very strange
but Russia has no Mediterranean access
with or without the annexation they're
trying to approve without turkey so
they're they have to be allies for this
war to resolve in Russia's favor
but they're in NATO what the hell's
going on they have nuclear weapons what
the hell is going on oh it's simple
Klaus Schwab had a meeting with Putin
and Biden and said we need to grid reset
everything let's pretend to have a war
and they're like okay that'll give us an
excuse to launch the nukes and then I'm
kidding by the way but hey man I I can
only say that cloud Schwab is probably
sitting back like this is war is very
good
yeah this wolf was inevitable we need
order
order
well and how much of this too is driven
just by the like the military industry I
mean it have we gotten to the point
where just we always need some kind of a
war we had Iraq we had Afghanistan we
got out of Afghanistan now it's Russia
after Russia is it going to be something
else I mean is it just a continual war
machine where we're feeding this beast
that's what Eisenhower told us it was
going to be and after Vietnam in the
early 70s they I mean there was just a
slew of like military interactions I'm
very in the dark about it's just they
they're so obfuscated in the in the
Balkans uh in like obviously Serbia
Kosovo with like in the Clinton years I
remember hearing about Serbia and Kosovo
and Bosnia like there was just bombs
going on I never knew what was what who
was who I just knew that we were
involved in all this death
um
yeah I think without without conflict
and places to blow up bombs with with
some sort of reason whether it's Faker
or real than the military industrial
complex will cease to function yes
sometimes I wonder if all this money is
being sent to Ukraine and is kind of
like to help replace the Lost revenue
from leaving Afghanistan in the Middle
East like 100 billion dollars yeah on
the books that have been sent over there
in the middle of the economic recession
they've set 100 billion dollars to some
country that we're not even allies with
and then what happens they buy weapons
from who
God knows the Chinese the Russians I
don't know where they're coming from
yeah and they're buying you know from us
it's our own money being given right
back to us there's a reason there's a
saying that war is a racket because it
is and the only winners of the war are
the people who finance uh the wars the
people who of course bankroll the sides
and sell the arms and the weapons
everyone else loses there's no real
winners in the war military people who
profit off of it military-industrial
complex grifting yeah for them it's like
we need to justify why we need more
weapons let's get mad at somebody and
claim they're bad and then go fight them
yeah well there's more pigs right well
first uh the recent U.S policy is hey
we're going to give these guys a bunch
of weapons and then a couple years later
these are the bad guys we gotta fight
these guys with all these weapons Saddam
Hussein he has he has chemical weapons
that we gave him to fight the Iranians
the the syrians they have all these
weapons they have all these Humvees and
trucks with American businesses on the
side of them we got to go fight them
they're gonna attack and kill us the
Libyan you know Gaddafi he's a very bad
guy we sold him a bunch of weapons but
he's a bad guy now we got to take him
out because he wants to do a gold dinar
uh so there it goes on and on and on I
can never stop the tally about it yeah
we gotta fight we gotta fight the
Russians in Afghanistan we got to give
him all the all the weapons oh no the
Taliban no they're bad now yeah we're
gonna go fight them I tweeted out a
video of this guy who went to
Afghanistan recently this video on
YouTube is called tourism and Taliban
controlled Afghanistan he went he
interviewed Taliban he's like what do
you think of Joe Biden and the big the
older Taliban member who's doing the
speaking was like we are Joe Biden did a
great job by leaving we hope he never
comes back you can see he left us all
this equipment that the Taliban is
driving around on right now we're very
grateful for Joe Biden oh yeah they love
him he's got a 98 approval rating over
there they call it Independence Day the
day 9 11 when we pull when we the
Taliban calls it Independence Day well
when we surrender when we surround a day
that we surrendered to the Taliban wow
thanks Joe Biden yeah we just well nine
trillion dollars making sure that we get
you know we replace the Taliban with the
Taliban the money well spent yeah ladies
and gentlemen
we got him oh boy we got him oh Hunter
Biden Daily Mail reports federal agents
have enough evidence to charge Hunter
Biden with tax crimes and making false
statement while buying gun bombshell
report claims decision lies in the hands
of U.S attorney in Delaware in Delaware
perfect they know all about the bidens
I'm sure we're going to see Hunter held
to account and then hey man The Dominoes
begin falling because once they get
Hunter he's gonna squeal like a pig and
he's gonna be like my dad did it all
he's a pedo he's pedo Peter here's the
laptop here's proof and then Joe Biden's
going down mark my words on November
12th they're the arrests no nothing's
gonna happen I haven't quite literally
nothing's gonna happen Hunter Biden's
gonna laugh at it Joe Biden's gonna do
nothing and even if they did charge
Hunter Joe Biden would be like here's a
here's a blanket pardon son free to go
yeah I thought you were reading the
latest cue drop there for a second
this I think is a way to scare Americans
into paying their taxes and not buying
guns I think they're gonna make Hunter a
poster boy for tax evasion and gun
illegal gun handling they're going to to
give them a slap on the wrist but enough
that's like people don't are super
afraid they don't want to cross the
government because the government is
looking out for tax and gun crimes that
is interesting because of all the things
they could have got him on to choose
those things I mean those are relatively
minor crimes compared to everything that
he's done uh with human trafficking
crack all that the deals with China tax
evasion buying a gun that's that seems
odd yeah it's not common of course they
want to scare people with it right now
they're they're willing to throw Hunter
under the bus whoever they are but like
you said Biden could pardon the guy he
probably won't he's probably gonna be
like well he needs to you know we got to
make an example out of Hunter but you'll
be okay no he'll do it he'll just pardon
him straight up yeah because Joe is not
going to be in I don't believe Joe would
be was going to run for president in
2024. he's going to be like I'm out I
don't care
if he pardons him it will set an example
that like paying your taxes isn't that
important you think he cares about that
no one no one else yeah I think he's
obsessed with making people pay taxes
right now that's why he hired
he's gonna make an example this is my my
projection is he'll make an example out
of Hunter these people are minor
Direction this guy is so dirty and
corrupt well he's not gonna nail him
he's just gonna you know punish him like
he's a 17 year old Hunter Biden could
destroy the Biden family with everything
he knows Joe is going to give him
everything he wants I think I think
Hunter's internet I think Joe will be
like we're gonna make an example out of
you to show people that paying taxes is
important I was like okay Dad you think
that cat is gonna be like sure thing Dad
no he's gonna be like no I'm not doing
that because he'd go don't make me go
and talk to them because I'll tell them
what you did with Ukraine and China but
he'd go down with him if he did if
Hunter turned on Joe they both go down
Hunter's too self-serving I don't I
don't know if he's going to go to prison
and Joe won't pardon him then he'll say
if I'm going down I'm taking you with me
I mean maybe he'll get like 60 days time
served in a in a cushy home arrest yeah
that that magical bracelet the gun
charge I'd be surprised but yeah if they
give him house arrest he probably like
sure thing pop yeah doing crackiness
well this is this is this sorry Hunter
man this is the same guy that had Secret
Service intervene when his gun was found
in a trash can in 2018. Secret Service
literally butted in and said oh no this
is a local police case we're gonna make
sure we're involved in this and and they
literally found a handgun
that was registered to him in a trash
can which is like and he got away with
it yeah yeah hold on hold on they're
saying they might charge him so not for
that specific charge what is it for
example he might he might not I mean
there's talks about this uh what is it
attorney general or uh prosecutor
there's talks about this prosecutor
being uh right wing and there's a
possibility of this happening I think
yeah it's a trump prosecutor yeah that
was appointed by him so people are
saying there's a small possibility here
but again the system has a way of
greasing the wheels here Joe Biden is an
extremely dirty human being that will
use every illicit means to of course
protect his inner circle and
um I could see a lot of shadowy things
happening behind the scenes putting
pressure on this prosecutor being like
this is my son you don't do this and
then the prosecutor's saying okay sure
do you think Hunter caves on his dad I
think I think there's a theory out there
that I think is plausible of Hunter
deliberately releasing a lot of this
stuff in order to get back at his dad
for a potential crimes that Hunter
committed against the President Hunter
might actually be the hero yeah you know
he's like sitting there and he's being
like a crackhead but for the American
people I'll make the sacrifice he's good
friends he's good friends with Tucker
Carlson what Hunter yes look up Hunter
Biden Tucker Carlson you could see it
they have a good relationship with each
other so well maybe potentially yeah
he's like giving all his information up
for money that's that's you know that
makes more sense to me uh money but also
maybe retribution maybe there's there's
something he calls his dad a pedo
apparently yeah that's listed as a
contact I could see like in 15 or 20
years after Joe Biden's passed away that
Hunter is like does a tell-all story
where he's like he was abusive he was
manipulative he got me involved in
Ukraine uh he put me in positions that I
didn't want to be you know just
demonizing look how horrible was big
sympathy for Hunter Hunter runs for
office the Biden name you know like crap
like that I can see I don't know the
Biden name is synonymous with mud at
this point because of like just
everything wrong with the economy this
is funny if you look at the polling for
Democrats the generic ballot they're
they're polling tracks alongside gas
prices to a certain degree now that gas
prices are going up Democrat polling is
going down because they're the ones who
are in charge and when gas prices go up
this is most people it really is simple
math most people don't know don't care
Russia nuclear war or whatever but I
tell you this you probably go to your
your friends your family and you're like
hey this nuclear war stuff is serious
they could you know we can go to war
people could die and they're going I
don't know what you're talking about I
don't care about that and you're like
your gas prices are up 50 cents well
hold on what I noticed that now I'm mad
it's because of Joe Biden's war in
Ukraine and I say Joe Biden's War
because I fully understand that Vladimir
Putin invaded Ukraine but Joe Biden
decided to involve the U.S in something
that doesn't involve us so that is his
War you can blame a lot on Putin but why
are we involved so if you want to talk
to people and you want to convince them
to pay attention to this you can be like
hey you know your gas is going up
because of this and that means you can't
pay your rent you're not gonna be able
to buy food it means food costs are
going to go up labor costs are going to
go up and you can thank Joe Budden well
he's burning through our our strategic
oil reserves right now too I mean oh
yeah man he's just he's just holding off
until the election as soon as the
election is over gas prices are going to
Skyrock because uh you know I don't know
how much reserves we have left but I
think we're at a kind of a record low so
8.80 gas and in California last week
yeah hell it was 89 cents when I was
when I was like 18. I mean if you're if
you're looking to have some kind of
large reformatting
an impactful new beginning but we're
still gonna deal oil even if there's a
gray reset we still need oil if they cut
off the oil I think like billions will
die like within the first few days of
oil getting cut off 60 million I think
is are the estimates between 20 and 60
minutes dude I'm looking at this
technology where a guy puts oil in his
like deoxygenated pressure chamber or to
puts plastic rather in his deoxygenated
pressure chamber and then turns it back
into oil and then can reuse the oil like
what kind of plastic and is the video
fake it was like a Japanese guy from
like six or seven years ago and it was
in a small scale man I saw a video of a
guy levitating objects
it was pretty basic and I think it's
still to be refined re-refined to be
able to use like gasoline but it was oil
I think people need to understand too
like P people like Greta tunberg when
she's like we have to stop the fossil
fuels now you need to imagine an iron
gauntlet on her hand and her slamming
the table because she's talking about
killing people yes Mass genocide's
called like cutting off fossil fuels
abruptly and outright will just kill
tens of millions instantly and then
within a few days I've done it with
famine you know that's but but give it a
few years and then there's going to be
famines power shortages and you're gonna
see look take a look at the population
growth charts and then right around the
Advent of fossil fuels it just goes
straight up it goes from like a
consistent 500 million people in the
world throughout history and then right
before the turn of the century it just
jumps to the billions and then it keeps
climbing exponentially and it's because
of this massive energy rich product if
you cut that off it's gonna go right
back down here's the video it's called
Uh Bill Gates is like yes yes
that's why it keeps trying this is the
machine reverts plastic back to oil it's
new inventions machine reverts plastic
backed oil it's from about 11 years ago
and the the name of the inventor is
acanori Ito he was the CEO of
blessed.co.ltd at the time the website
now that link is no longer working I
don't know what the status of this
technology is right now but I mean if
one guy in a small company can make this
on a small scale where's our industrial
plastic recycling we got a CBC report
apparently they're doing it big pile of
trash and these tiny pieces of plastic
is it what you're talking about I'm not
sure no this is a Canadian company says
they figured how to do it that would be
a diesel fuel that we're getting out of
here wow
gasoline from plastic this is the two
that we've set up to do plastic is just
like oil and it came out of the ground
at one time the same way we are taking
plastic and we are we are converting it
using a process called pyrolysis where
we're converting it into a fuel fuel so
we know that Bill Gates has people who
monitor conversations about him so you
know of course when the show starts they
tell them uh Mr Gates Tim cast iron well
turn it on the TV and now he's watching
and he sees this clip and he goes what
and he's like slamming the table and
he's gonna call he's like shut him down
we don't want people to live you solved
my problem
no no no no no his problem isn't the use
of fossil fuels his problem is that the
use of fossil fuels makes more people
um I want to ask them I want to ask this
question because maybe it's a little
philosophical what do you think drives
this anti-human bent in these people
Schwab Bill Gates the demons Gravity the
pain of being sucked down to a planet
the pain the physical pain that we we've
become desensitized to makes people hate
themselves to answer your question I I
think there's a combination of of
Satanist demons people with mental
health issues but but more consensus
more more
um in a more simple way throughout human
history there has always been someone
trying to conquer the world that's not
something that's out of the ordinary it
is the norm whether it's Genghis Khan
Napoleon Caesar whoever it may be they
become so empowered by other individuals
that that power corrupts them absolute
power corrupts absolutely and these
individuals have reached such power such
wealth that the they are going along
with what Hitler did with what Mao did
what Stalin did trying to conquer and
control human life for their own
personal benefit sociopathic demons is
one easy way to describe them another
way another way to describe them is of
course just saying throughout human
history there have always been these
types of people that challenge us and
try to conquer everything yeah Alexander
the Great he was on a conquering spree
going east taking like all of you know
what is it Ursa Minor that East uh
Western Asia and it got to the point
where he conquered so much of Persia
maybe even all of Persia and then his
generals were like okay Alex we've had
enough we we want to go home to see our
wives it's been 15 years you promised
you know this is all about making our
lives better and Alex is like we must go
on we must continue and they fought and
he kept taking them they're like we're
done and then one day Alexander woke up
and he was very sick from the night
before I think they poisoned him I mean
the theory is that his General's poison
because they couldn't they couldn't stop
him once you get into that state of mind
got conquering and he thought he was the
son of God like he was like educated by
Aristotle his mother told him he was a
God and a god manly he thought he was
there to conquer Earth and the only way
to stop someone like that at least to
his generals was he had to stop him
because he wasn't going to stop why do
you think well yeah I don't know I do
think it's a spiritual battle kind of
that you alluded to that you know if if
we were created by God we're Made In His
Image you know and there is a Satan you
know you have to assume that that he
hates the image of God you know we he he
he despises us and and I think if you
know if those forces are at work in the
world then there's always going to be
those people who rise up and and who
kind of just naturally hate God's image
you know the on the earth and and so
it's probably kind of his oldest time
like you said
just takes different iterations you know
through it throughout history
there's always some jerk taking a dump
in the punch bowl it's got to be like
and that's history like fear of being
attacked like what zielinski was saying
we need to preemptively strike so that
they don't attack us like what the
Romans did we need to conquer everyone
around us so that we don't get attacked
because if you actually are attacked and
your city's sacked like Rome happened to
roam in the early days there's like 200
years to recover from that like it can
annihilate a civilization if you're
attacked so there's this idea of like I
need to conquer the Earth so that the
Earth doesn't conquer me do you think
we're bored too we just we're so
comfortable and happy and we have
everything we need and it mankind gets
to a point where they just get bored and
we just have to destroy something so we
can build it up again life used to be
about survival right 80 90 of your day
was just wake up work otherwise you
don't have food winter is coming are you
ready
now we've got heating Refrigeration we
can have strawberries in the dead of
winter we can have avocados fresh
tableside guacamole prepared to order in
January now that's something to behold
so it's just we just we you know they
talk about like we got to end Global
poverty and blah blah blah and I'm like
I get it but there's no such thing as
ending poverty because even the poorest
people in the world have access to
technologies that were Unthinkable a
hundred years ago not that they have
like consistent access to it but even
the United States the poorest person in
the U.S can get clean drinking water
very very easily you walk into a
McDonald's and you're like water you're
good try doing that in some other parts
of the world where there's no water and
they're desperate yeah well I don't
think that also explains it because
throughout human history when there was
no drinking water tribes used to kill
other tribes whether it was Native
Americans whether it was Europeans there
was always someone trying to kill
someone else for their resources for for
their clean water for their food and for
their you know energy and ability to
survive as well so this has been
happening for a very very long time now
it's it only gets a lot more
sophisticated it only gets a lot more
complicated because of these
technological advancements that allow
people to hide behind the scenes and to
impose their will in a fifth
generational Warfare way where people
don't even realize that they're being
depopulated that they're being
chemically attacked that they're being
castrated that they're being taught and
manipulated in a way that they become
self-destructive and destroyed
themselves as a would-be dictator is
literally pulling the strings and
calling the shots without anyone even
knowing their name I think that's a more
likely scenario with what we're dealing
with right now than previously in
archaic times where you would stab
someone and you would go into battle now
the battle I think is in our minds and I
think that battle is expanding in a way
that that there's no denying that it
exists especially with the
dehumanization that we have seen within
the last few years yeah I was thinking
about the ballistics and how they've
changed War like being able to not have
to look your enemy in the eye when you
kill them but then I'm thinking about
the Romans and how they basically
genocided the Gauls they went through
all of France and just millions of
people were slaughtered at the hands of
the Romans and I think it gets to the
point where the killers enjoy killing
like they they learn to dehumanize these
things that they're attacking and they
enjoy the abusive Behavior like it's a
powerful rush you gain from it you get
food and money and jewels and women
after you make the kill and it's like
addictive and and and and when it
becomes easy for them yeah and they
think about you know these people have
ideas I don't like hey
it's just that much easier they don't
even think of as people too it's so
crazy how the dehumanization can happen
when you just call them savage or
whatever you want yeah I'm telling you
they treat us like chickens
look this is what I was saying this
earlier today on my other show the
government deeply cares about you your
government cares about you they care
about your well-being and they want you
to be healthy and happy
in so far as you can provide labor for
them everything else your love your life
your your your faith your dreams
completely meaningless right and if you
get in the way of their labor machine
you are expendable so they care about
you as much as I care about say chickens
like I don't want harm to befall them
but if I have to get rid of you know a
Cocky Rooster he's going out to cocktown
or he's getting chopped up for lunch
they give me eggs I don't care what else
they do in the meantime but if they
start doing things I don't like then you
go in and you deal with them that's how
they view people we provide labor we do
work it allows them to live in their
Elysium golden towers with golden
toilets but if we start acting out of
line speaking up and challenging their
Authority the reality is we aren't
chickens we are humans and humans are
smart smart enough so if there are smart
people who can challenge them at the top
that's a problem I got nothing to worry
about there's zero chance Roberto Jr is
going to figure out how to come in here
and take this company over he's a
rooster near zero chance near zero
chance there's a small percentage for
human beings when we do shows like this
the people who are currently whole
holding the keys to the chicken coop in
which we are all imprisoned they have to
be careful because people are smart
enough to break free from that and that
means you ain't getting the eggs anymore
that's why we have politics because
people are too smart so we need a mind
control system to utilize their
intelligence without allowing them
to seize control and that's possibly why
we've seen such a ramp up with with
what's happening globally in the you
know the great reset and all this Wars
is because of the information age what's
happened you know this has been this is
the Advent of the printing press you
know with the internet we now have all
this access to information without
Gatekeepers and so it it's it does seem
like kind of the powers that be are very
violently reacting to that boy do they
regret that one yeah oh yeah but to add
to your point in talking about politics
I think politics is just there to
placate the population I think it's
there to just convince people that they
actually have a say in things when they
actually don't it's it's like a
Fisher-Price toy that you give to a
child that you just distract them with
thinking that they're actually cooking a
meal when they're actually not I think
that our political system has run the
same exact way and there's powerful
people behind the scenes calling the
shots getting whatever they want
convincing you brainwashing you and
screwing you over every single day and
they're doing it more than ever and
there was even a Mainline study that we
talked about a couple years ago I think
on this show typically talking about how
our form of government is a joke it
doesn't exist we don't live under a
democracy we don't have a democracy
because special interests always get
their way what people want never happens
so top plutonomy plutocracy I think no
plutonomy was the report I think it was
from Citigroup okay yeah they said the
United States is not a democracy it's a
plutonomy where the wealthiest control
the system yeah a great example that is
super delegates the Democratic party no
matter who votes for what when you go to
the polls at the very end the super
delicate company like actually we're
going to make Joe Biden the nominee like
you're not voting for The nominee you're
voting for people that you hope will
nominate the person you want them to
vote for it's not democracy in the
slightest I like this plutonomy yeah
this is the documents the plutonomy PDF
Citigroup Equity strategy plutonomy
buying luxury expanding Global
explaining Global imbalances the world
is dividing into two blocks the
plutonomy and the rest the U.S UK and
Canada are the key plutonomies economies
powered by the wealthy Continental
Europe X Italy and Japan are the
egalitarian block
Equity risk premium blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah the plutonomy
machine economy is driven by the wealthy
that's China right now the industrial
wealth wealth is distribution wealth is
production it does not about how many
dollars you have it's about what you're
producing and the Chinese people are
producing like mad at the moment we're
producing a lot of paper money so
there's that yeah that's good true yeah
we've chosen a private company to do
that for us at their own discretion the
Federal Reserve yeah yeah plutonomy is a
term that refers to the science of the
production of distribution of wealth in
modern times Citigroup analysts
beginning with AJ Kapoor in 2005 have
used the term describe an economy in
which the rich are the driving forces
and Main beneficiaries of economic
growth others including Noam Chomsky
have used the term to refer to a nation
or economy in which wealth is
concentrated in the hands of a few
and there you go that's where you are
and then they can use that for Access
for lobbying for manipulation for media
control and then they create little
underlings to go on Twitter and lie to
you and know they lie to you and that's
it it's just some people are just
evil yeah I was thinking about this when
they I saw uh some I can't remember what
I was watching but they were like
Republicans are trying to bring about
evil into this country or whatever and
then I thought about that I'm like well
they know that's not serious like these
these people know that they're the ones
who are lying because there's no way you
can believe every single Lie from the
mainstream media unless you know like
there's no way you can keep saying this
and believe these lies unless there's
something wrong with you or you're just
pushing the lies
and so what I think is they view freedom
and liberty as chaos and evil whereas we
view authoritarianism and manipulation
evil so to them they're like these
people are evil they want just chaos
people doing everything and then it all
burns down in climate change and
whatever I picture them like the guy in
the basement that paints the little you
know figures nothing nothing wrong with
that but like you know that has the has
the the the scenes set up and everything
just so and everything pose maybe like a
little train set or something like that
and you know imagine if those Figures
were about to you know have agency or
free will and it's just if a guy loses
his mind that's kind of they're they're
people tinkering with a with a train set
in their basement that's obsessed with
order yeah Libertarians are obsessed
with chaos maybe not but I mean if you
become obsessed with chaos or order you
become very dangerous there's got to be
a balance yeah there it does because too
much order is show me your papers or get
in the cell too much chaos is I lit it
on fire I don't even know where the fire
is anymore yeah well the really great
and and really bad thing about our
current dichotomy is that in this larger
War people are are literally killing and
taking themselves out
um it's it's a really bad thing because
it's horrible to see and you try to
prevent it but but a lot of times it's
very difficult to do so but on another
aspect it's a good thing because at the
same time it could be stopped just by
information just by knowledge just by
people being able to talk to each other
in a transparent accountable full honest
real truthful way and the internet
provides us a small opportunity to do
that but it's being limited every single
day because of that particular reason
this is why this this move by Twitter
again it's going to be interesting to
see how it plays out but uh I think it
provides a huge potential that could
really upend and shift things will it
happen I'm skeptical but I I do see it
as something that could change the world
for the better as people realize hey
maybe I shouldn't be hurting myself
maybe I shouldn't be treating myself bad
maybe I should start eating better maybe
I should start working out maybe I
shouldn't just listen and do everything
that they tell me to do and I keep
getting screwed over by it and I think
the more people who have those
conversations and and actually open
themselves up to fixing themselves they
won't be killing themselves and blowing
themselves up figuratively mentally
speaking Yeah drug addiction like uh and
I'm talking about high fructose corn
syrup sugars is well types of drugs like
that something the government can't
really kind of control by Banning
certain substances but the whole like
obesity epidemic because like you were
saying earlier the government wants
workers they want chickens that just do
their chicken thing and lay the eggs but
then why are they letting people get
obese I don't think that I think it's
just it's bigger than gut like economy
is is the market is stronger than our
government it always probably has I mean
we have a a very few food companies
controlling most of the food supply
chain now and and they're very well
connected in government and and uh I
think they have a lot of power you know
over what goes in our food over what
goes in our you know on our nutrition
labels
um and and so I think I think a lot of
our our diet our American diet is is
dictated by the lobbyist for these
companies in Washington I want to jump
to the store we got from timcast.com
Biden pardons Federal convictions for
low-level marijuana possession today we
begin to write these wrongs Biden said
the pardon also applies to lawful
permanent residents who have been
charged with simple possession as well
as individuals who have been charged but
not yet stood trial quote as I've said
before no one should be in jail just for
using or possessing marijuana today I'm
taking steps to end our failed approach
allow me to lay them out okay uh I agree
with this I said Trump should have done
the same thing I don't like Joe Biden
and this earns no brownie points as far
as I'm concerned because I think this is
just pandering I I but I still look
respectable uh credit credit where
credit is due I think they should have
been doing this a long time ago I think
Donald Trump should have done it I don't
trust Biden actually do anything I don't
think Democrats are actually going to
you know take marijuana off schedule one
but what do you guys think
do we know how many people this
represents
I mean are we talking about thousands
millions I think it's thousands I have
seen that at the federal level right now
there are zero that's what I heard I
didn't check it out I didn't check it
out for this minor thing that they're
they're classing it under what is a
simple possession there's no one which
would be really interesting I did see a
meme earlier so this could just be a
publicity stunt though oh yeah it sure
could be I mean I saw a meme earlier
today about Kamala Harris looking
through the blinds very sadly as Joe
Biden releases all the people's shoes so
carefully putting in jail for marijuana
I kind of lower Camelot I like the way
this sounds though I haven't looked into
it yet it's similar to that AI Bill of
Rights that they proposed a few days ago
I think that even an incompetent
government can get stuff right and you
know no one's pure evil or pure good so
in a way I mean definitely we should
make marijuana not schedule one narcotic
completely insane it's a plant it's like
an herb yeah just don't overuse the
thing it's freaking drug it's potent you
know the War on Drugs is a farce that
just abuses people that have substance
abuse problems that are never dealt with
and only made worse and people are made
harder criminals and bigger criminals
just by going into our Penitentiary
system so I think they're they're
reaching in a bag they're like holy crap
cow we screwed these people over really
bad we we robbed them of all their money
we robbed them of of energy we robbed
them of any kind of potential let's just
give them a little crumb here and let's
hope that affects the upcoming elections
because I think they are desperate I
think the the War on Drugs just like the
war on terror is is just manufactured to
control populations it's it's good to
see a portion of it stop but will this
actually have real effect again I'm
skeptical so yeah he's saying that he's
calling on the uh attorney general to
initiative process of reviewing how
marijuana is scheduled under federal law
because it's considered more serious
than fentanyl which is just insane it's
so crazy
yep why didn't Trump do it though
good question
I guess why why why
I don't know if I say he was going to do
it before the the split between the
traditional conservatives who do vote
for him and the Maga types who are more
libertarian he thought he wouldn't get
realized I think yeah I think it would
have potentially split his base and and
been harmful to him political he might
not have won if he didn't do it oh wait
he didn't I don't think it would have
been harmful to him at all I think there
would have been some people who would
have been like I don't think he's right
to do but there's no way I'm voting for
Biden you know let the states decide
jeez like do you think any Trump
supporter is going to vote for Joe Biden
for doing this
no no he's got to earn my respect in
many many ways more than one or two
moves the student loan thing for
instance all of a sudden he went back on
it they were gonna give ten thousand
dollars everyone that has a loan and
then it turns out not if you have a
private loan only if you had government
loans only sorry and there's so many
people with private loans that aren't
getting them oh they're gonna walk the
whole thing back of course it's gonna be
like the day before the election is
gonna be like oh yeah how about that but
like crumpled up and throw in the garden
there was no public and I didn't see
like a public
press conference about not doing it they
just quietly were like that's what all
this stuff is he's just throwing stuff
against the wall he's going to keep
doing that until election day it's
because he can't do it anyway he's got
nothing else this is why we have this
weird pseudo War you know with Russia
because they're not allowed to do it Joe
Biden doesn't have the authority to
forgive student loans so naturally
within a month or a few months they're
like oh yeah he's not actually doing
that
like imagine if Joe Biden came I was
like I'm gonna give everybody who votes
for me a thousand dollars
he can't so it's like you he's lying you
know people believe it I guess that's
government though right
what else is new half the time at least
I'm really that's generous it's a lot of
like projections about what they're
calling I mean are you kidding me I just
I just finally
I'll say like we're going to fill in the
blank and like yeah you didn't do it yet
wait do it and then tell me you did it
then that at least isn't alive well it's
like Lydia was saying there might not
even be a single person I just pulled it
up I don't know if this is correct but
I'm hearing that 99 of federal drug
offenders are sentenced for trafficking
uh I haven't fact checked this so
someone could fact check this and that
only 92 people were sentenced for
marijuana possession in the federal
system in 2017 out of nearly 20 000 uh
drug convictions so um yeah it's like if
Joe Biden came out and was like all
those you know children who are
negatively impacted by the Alien
Invasion will receive a million dollars
from the government you're like okay
that's zero it's like hey hey we're
helping kids hey man right kept that
promise because people will hear this
this is brilliant man you know in terms
of manipul relating people this is just
so good
announcing that you're going to be
partying a tiny tiny group of people but
then saying there are thousands of
people who were previously convicted
convincing people that you actually did
a thing when there's no one that's for
the most part being effective now look
to those 92 people in 2017 or whatever
I'm sure there was 100 in 2018 19 20 21
22. uh so we're looking at maybe you
know several hundred people I'm sure
their lives will be improved by this
hell yeah but he's not doing what I
suggested Trump do which was basically
pardon anybody for any crime relating to
any non-violent crime who didn't plead
down so that means if they had like
large possession or trafficking I don't
care yeah trafficking for references
when you have 25 kilograms or more or
300 or more plants of marijuana here's
what you do everybody who's been
convicted for that
if they didn't plead down from a violent
offense they should be they should have
to go through a mandatory licensing
process and then be released
that's it yeah
like you were you were trafficking all
of this Agricultural Product without a
permit so it's a 50 fine get your permit
have a nice day get rid of the permit
permitting system right away
I'm disgusted by that time I'm just
saying like the appropriate thing to do
is you know it's it's less people be and
if they're not hurting anyone if they're
just deciding to to smoke something or
put something in their butt it's their
choice in their decision even though
they should be informed though that
there are extremely negative
consequences that we're not being told
when it comes to marijuana and marijuana
is becoming more potent is becoming more
dangerous and does have negative effects
on some human beings so people need to
understand there's dangers in in doing
this but at the same time the government
coming in and throwing you in jail for
doing this is not going to solve the
problem I had some old uh old hippies
talking to me about how pot today is
nothing like it was in the 70s like in
the 70s it was weak and they were like
yeah so you'd smoke and it was like you
know now it's just like boom it's very
powerful stuff so so maybe you know we
got to be careful about all drugs but
you know look man my attitude is if you
want to go into your closet and you know
smoke
inject I don't know whatever as long as
you're not hurting other people
I I actually think that regulation is
the is the best way towards helping
people ending the Violence by pushing it
into the black market you only create a
space for this so the appropriate thing
to do in my opinion is legalize with
restrictions if people if people are
addicted to opiates give them a space
where you can go and help them and make
sure they don't die from it yeah instead
they tell you well you might as well go
hide in a basement and then when you OD
too bad no one's going to call for help
because they're scared to go they're
scared when you can't get your
prescription filled you'll go down to
Skid Row to find somebody with fentanyl
yeah they run out of their Oxycontin or
whatever they look for something else
because they don't yeah man but the
thing about weed is it is legal it's
it's um it is legal I'm like what am I
okay let's go with it no it's um
addictive and you know mildly I think
physically definitely psychologically
addictive and giving it to kids is
messed up I Used to Know kids in high
school that I never smoked until I was
23 but like in high school they were
just slow and dull and like bored with
school and like maybe they were slowing
down to school anyway but they would be
more slow and more dull when they would
come into work smelling like pot and
like you know weren't mean or anything
we're just like I don't know yeah it
should be just like alcohol you know and
and you know marijuana does have some
medicinal properties but at the same
time there's also other forms of
marijuana that will absolutely knock you
on your butt and have very severe
negative consequences especially if
you're a child as it rewires your brain
and and predominantly does make a lot of
people lazy some people would actually
make some energized some people actually
gives them inspiration some people would
help some people it hurts just like
anything in life lazy all right yeah
when I when I went to Colorado I and I I
for the first time I I remember having
this thought like holy cat it's kind of
dangerous for me because I I right now I
feel like I would be completely happy
never accomplishing anything ever again
yeah this is everything's good right now
it's big part of the transhumanist
agenda is put you in the universe and
Alex they just want you sitting down
yeah I'm surprised the government's not
giving out free weed at this point I see
them doing this a couple years from now
being like yes get high just just
totally forget about everything just
just go on the couch they're gonna sit
there don't worry about anything there's
a nice pod next to that couch that we're
also going to give you next will be uh
what was the children of men remember
that movie when they were handing that
suicide kits to everybody these little
boxes yeah they're gonna they're gonna
try and create some kind of patentable
derivative that they can control the
price on then they're going to say
everybody needs this because it's it
distresses and then they're gonna say
the government should pay for it
everybody gets taxed without realizing
it and then they're paying for the
thousand dollar pills it's Marinol it's
called Marinol and it's uh International
non-proprietary name is dronabinol also
known as Delta 9
tetrahydrocannabinol I guess they've
they've pharmaceuticalized it Marinol
syndrome and adversa adversa whatever
you do it's great yeah whatever you do
do not smoke it's a challenge whatever
you do do not smoke the government weed
yeah whatever you do cheap and free Luke
don't eat them it's gonna be insurance
is going to cover it what was that movie
Children of Men Children of Men yeah
we're we're closely approaching that
that future and that's okay if you
haven't watched that movie it's it's
soon to be a documentary did you see the
videos out of Canada where the guys like
he calls the hotline and they're like if
you need help dying let us know oh yeah
yeah they're like pushing people to that
yeah well and we're almost seeing that a
little bit in the states too with
insurance companies that that will you
know they won't cover your your surgery
or their or your treatment but they will
cover you know your your uh what you
call it your death With Dignity you know
we'll give you painkillers until you die
let's there's kind of that movement just
scoot people along let's let's move it
along here wow and uh yeah you see it
you wanna you wanna know where we're
headed in 10 15 years look at Canada
look at Europe yeah that's where we're
headed ethics oversight over
pharmaceutical companies and insurance
companies I mean it's got to be like
governmental ethics that's a big part of
our government is ethics that's the
dudes that wrote the US Constitution
were ethicists they understood religious
and moral ethics and that's why there
were so many of them they didn't agree
on the Logics and the literals all the
time but they got like the ethics for
the most part you know the slavery thing
was still debatable at the time so I
feel like the founding fathers really
understood human nature which is
probably what what made them strong
ethicists and I think you're correct I
think the problem now is that I don't
think government ethics is ethical I
don't think it's ever a good idea for a
government ethics board to oversee
something like the pharmaceutical
company I think they're too tightly too
tightly combined I think it needs to be
an independent
um outside organization I have seen
Marinol used it was used to stimulate
appetite for an older lady who was
really struggling to eat so it does have
like good purposes but it's not
I'm from Colorado so I've seen what
marijuana does to people and people used
to tell me all the time oh I can cure
anything it cures cancer what are you
talking about you're just being a downer
I was like I have seen it change people
and I've had people tell me I wish I'd
never started marijuana or I wish I
hadn't started as young as I did it
changed my overall life experience
hugely negative but that said it should
not be illegal I could say I missed a
lot of opportunities because I was
stoned but that's blaming the weed it
was my own fault like I had to make a
final decision I could have went video
games it could have been alcohol you
know human beings find something yeah
yeah but it was me I I made the choice
not to go do the things that I feel like
I missed out on it wasn't and I blamed
the weed for years and stressed my
family out about it and then they
started freaking out about wheat it
wasn't the weed it was me it was my own
personal lazy choice
so you got to make sure that whatever's
giving you that dopamine hit it's a it's
a positive thing with the with the
future I think South Park said it well
when um it's like they're they're
talking to the kids about their future
selves like they hire this company that
sends in fake versions of them from the
future who are like hey guys they're
smoking weed and then I became a loser
and then I finally at the end of Randy's
like son you know there's nothing really
bad about smoking pot other than it
makes you okay with being bored and then
when you're older you'll find that
you're not good at anything yeah plus
the government chips in all the drugs
they usually have through the CIA
especially as we found out through the
Iran Contra Scandal and I could keep
going but there's also some other
breaking news happening right now I
don't know if you guys seen us from the
Associated Press they're talking about
how Biden at a fundraiser in New York
talked about how Putin is quote not
joking about tactical nuclear weapons uh
Armageddon risk at highest level since
Cuban Missile Crisis so these are words
from the president of the United States
specifically talking about the dangers
that all of us face because of his
Reckless foreign policy that has brought
us to what he describes himself as
Armageddon which so this is this is
actually breaking right now so much so
it's one sentence Biden quote Putin not
joking about tactical nuclear weapons
Armageddon risk at highest levels since
Cuban Missile Crisis well hold on maybe
people might need that putt yeah let's
think about it don't write that off too
soon do they have marijuana
iodine pills right they're gonna start
giving out Marinol and potassium iodide
and they're going to beg the first one
is to help keep you alive by protecting
your thyroid the second one is to chill
you out
I think that uh fear of nuclear war
benefits the military-industrial complex
so if Biden is functioning as a
mouthpiece for that or if he's just
completely an NPC just afraid of like
normal everyday stimuli that like the
more intelligent evolve people can kind
of see around and understand the basics
of I don't know the White House will
walk this back tomorrow yes he used the
word Armageddon I mean like you know you
know Peter Ducey or whoever is is going
to be in the present you know like are
we headed towards Armageddon Korean
Jean-Pierre and she's going to be like
she's going to flip through her notebook
and and then she's going to say
something that's like well you know
Armageddon that's a word and words have
meaning yes and when when a meaning is
brought up people have to wonder why
because Armageddon that's an interesting
thing to say and then they're like okay
I don't I don't what and she'll be back
I answered your question she has the
Obama kids we uh we we very much uh does
that uh a lot we believe and and the
president's been very clear and and he's
been very clear from the beginning about
what we've said about what we believe
and what we want to do and and
Armageddon you know but you're missing
the snoot when she does it yeah Barack
Obama does the uh uh we uh but what she
does is she does that um and she closes
her eyes and looks down like that you're
so stupid
you really I'm speaking people who judge
does it too it's real Annoying like
Obama bought a genre of politicians that
uh say ah and uh and uh talk like this
uh there's Kareem Jean-Pierre but again
I think uh uh what's his name those are
people who don't believe in it a little
bit
um and who are are abiding time in their
mind to think of the lie that's that's
people who who need that many parts
that's what she's doing we have no
Foundation they have no beliefs that
just spill out they just absolutely all
politics and that's how you know Ben
Shapiro is the most honest person ever
so
it's just like there's no opportunity
for him to think of anything it goes
straight from the heart out of his mouth
doesn't even touch his lungs I I feel
like that's actually a fair observation
because he does speak very quickly and
very directly and I don't think that
speaking quickly is a marker that you're
telling the truth because we've known a
lot of people who could really spin
really fast it's actually really
impressive but it's possible that
telling the truth is just easier and it
makes it quicker for you to access those
like Naturals yeah it's nice right
I found that releasing my past secrets
on YouTube videos it was humiliating but
I've got like a hundred of them where
I'm just talking about my past and my
secrets and all of a sudden I didn't
they didn't pop into my head in the
middle of conversations I didn't have to
remember or think like was I lying or
was I am I hiding something here you
just kind of flow with whatever yeah I
want you to do me a favor I want you to
make me a promise that if a nuclear
strike is imminent where we live and
There Is No Escape
I want you to stand atop the van driving
full speed holding American flag while
blasting It's the End of the World As We
Know by REM you like that song well I
mean for this scenario yeah while we
hide in the bunker with our iodine pills
no I'm saying I don't want you to die in
The Blaze of Glory unless there's no
other choice but then it would just be
the greatest endings you know to any
story oh yeah when power 108 turned into
107.9 the end they played that song for
24 hours in Ohio northeast Ohio what's
up dogs if you're from Northeast Ohio in
the 80s you remember that that night it
was the I remember uh because I'm from
Chicago q101 changed it was like a rock
station it turned to like talk radio or
something and then it just flopped
miserably so I changed it back but my
favorite thing about q101 is that I'm
sure even today I don't know I haven't
been to Chicago in a while I'm sure
they're still just playing Stone Temple
Pilots like they never stopped playing
1990s music like 92. that's the people
who are listening to the radio I mean
who else is this they never changed yeah
this is this is interesting cultural
stagnation not just in that you know
because I I grew up you put on q101 in
Chicago and they're playing grunge and
it was Modern and then 10 years later
they're still playing these songs with
some new music and then it's 20 years
later and I'm just like man they're
still playing you know Stone double
pilots and like Pearl Jam and stuff I
bet they're still they're probably still
doing it today if they exist I don't
know again I haven't been there but then
I'm just looking at a lot of these bands
I talked about this a little bit the
other days that you're surprised they're
in their 50s and they're still making
new albums yes and why is it that 311 or
I don't know if it's new well I mean
it's still touring yeah you know yeah
but why is it that back in the day at a
certain age the music stopped like you
were too old and you were just like well
we're gonna shift you know and do
something else they become record
producers they'd work in the industry
now it's like 50 year olds still putting
out albums like what is that is it
because they don't have families well
they did like the eagles went for a long
time the Beatles now the Beatles broke
up no Stones obviously obviously stones
death will change like Zeppelin lost
their drummer um and they were like
we're done but I but I think a lot of it
is that obviously if you're like the
Beatles you never stop your Market is
working but a lot of bands fell out of
favor with the current trends but for
some reason I I think I actually I think
it's simple the internet it used to be
that if the radio wouldn't play your
song anymore because it was outdated
they'd be like look people don't want to
buy this stuff anymore you're that was
it you're off the radio and now you're
retired and now you're a husband these
days it's like I got followers on
Spotify don't need to stop at all the
radio is meaningless so now it's just
you can always be big somewhere yeah we
went to hot top we were at the mall we
walked past Hot Topic on the window for
our topic is the uh Nightmare Before
Christmas right I'm like yo that movie's
30 years old 80s no it's 90 90 93 or
four or something like that I'm like
it's a 30 year old movie and young kids
are I'm like everyone in there is a
young person
I I couldn't imagine when I was a kid
walking into the mall and there was a
store that didn't pretend to be a retro
store selling everything from the 60s
yeah
well I think there's nothing you talk
about cultural stagnation there's like
nothing uh
really new coming out anymore you know
movies TV music it's all rehashes
there's nothing original arts and a huge
slump and so I feel you know people kind
of are sticking with the people who
innovated in the 90s 80s 60s there there
is actually a new show that I think is
really really good that I've been
watching Power for no for uh you know
it's been about it's been a couple
months now and uh man the stories are
just compelling they're funny they make
you laugh make you cry starring and
Crossing by the way cast Castle it's a
great show I got emotional at the end
did you see yesterday's episode I I it's
touching the MU we've we've integrated
some powerful music just a great scene
with Chris and I at the end me and Chris
like nobody falls off the tree as we're
shooting it's like a leaf actually fell
off the tree in the middle of the shot
it was just so natural it was so
beautiful wait you're not talking about
this week's up you're talking about this
week's episode like yesterday's episode
Civil War yeah the end of Civil War the
the the shot is is stunning oh stunning
cinematic
but uh yeah I highly recommend going to
timcast.com and checking out the cast
Castle series because it is new but so
so people only watch what they already
like they don't want to see anything new
so that's why the office just keeps
getting replayed over and over again so
there's no reason to do things it used
to be that there was a finite amount of
space and these networks were trying to
be fresh by making new things but now
it's it's it doesn't matter anymore look
I just watched Breaking Bad For the
First Time a couple weeks ago and now
I'm I'm about to finish Better Call Saul
which you know to be fair Better Call
Saul did just finish but these are like
old Breaking Bad was old it took me 10
years to watch it I think I watched The
Sopranos a couple months ago loved it
incredible but again just like you it's
all it's there's too much existential
stress on people to be creative these
days I think if you're stressed out it's
hard to be creative like in the 90s
people didn't care man they were doing
heroin they didn't think like they were
just like rock rock and roll until they
died those dudes like well I also think
too that with streaming and with the
internet content has increased
exponentially we've never ever had more
volume in terms of content than we have
now but the talent pool for writing
acting you know creatives has not grown
at all so it's it's all spread out more
thin you know so you have you have a lot
more content much less quality and so
it's it's really hard to find like I
mean the office for example you there
really hasn't been a comedy that has
come out since the office that has
matched that well there was one there
was one called the office remember the
office came out and then they made
another one called the office yeah what
the British one came out it's called the
office Ricky Gervais and then they
immediately remade it because it's like
cultural stagnation they couldn't even
think of a new show they just remade the
office
yeah but it was still good but it was
just a remake and it could never be made
today you watch old office office
episodes you'd never see that oh man 30
Rock in in the first season Tina Fey
she's playing Liz Lemon says that she
tells her friend she voted for Obama but
she actually voted for McCain imagine a
modern SNL show where the main character
says I tell everybody I voted for
Hillary but I actually voted for Trump
twice no way they would ever allow that
that joke would not fly yeah uh the
office diversity day I haven't watched
the office but I just watched the small
clip of that that would not be okay
today yeah
for our for cast Castle but it was
brilliant hilarious some racy stuff I
think that we can we do I can't spoil
this thing but we do have
um we have a special guest coming out
next week and we're working on one of
the most uh hilariously offensive shows
we'll ever do yeah I wrote a scene for
it last night and I can't I can't say
too much but it's in line with what Luke
is talking about diversity day so it has
to do with the company and how all the
employee always have to go through
training and it'll be really really
funny dude cast Castle is legit man is
it gonna be like shockingly offensive
and a lot of people it keeps getting
better next I want to upgrade our sound
quality so it's the same room tone
everywhere so it's like the same sound
you don't hear differences and the same
lighting so once we get a Sound and
Lighting rig it's basically expanding I
think what we need to do is establish
that it's good enough to keep doing and
then once that's established we build
out I think the crew I think we need a
showrunner somebody who's got experience
having done shows like this before can
come in and be like ABCD is what you're
missing and then and then we're good to
go you know consultant or something like
that or maybe something longer standing
but I'm really excited for uh there's a
the currently there's one being filmed
today uh like this week which will come
out Tuesday but what's going to be
filmed next week is probably going to I
imagine everybody who likes our show is
going to absolutely love what we do and
then there's going to be a bunch of
videos posted by a bunch of leftist
organizations who are going to be like
yeah but it'll be so good that it's
indisputable that's the thing you want I
mean I'm okay with people complaining
about it but it's got to be so good when
you finally see the source that you're
like dang we got big news my friends big
news here
Shaggy's black Shaggy from Scooby-Doo is
now officially black and so is Velma oh
wait that's the Rockstar there we go
that's that's a bad one about uh here's
Mama Velma I think I don't know if she's
black maybe she's like Indian like Mindy
Kaling oh yeah but uh what the most you
know I'm really offended by we have this
uh discussing film it's like a first
look at Shaggy Daphne and Fred voiced by
Sam Richardson Constance Wu and Glenn
Howerton in HBO Max's adult animated
Velma series I just want to point to
point point out the most offensive thing
here is they change Shaggy he's not it's
it's nor killed he's fired Norville he's
fired Shaggy can't get a job that's not
[ __ ] it's supposed to be Shaggy but he's
replacing okay okay
fact check for all the Nerds they did I
think it was in A Pup Named Scooby-Doo
as a show they established that Shaggy's
real name was Norville that's why
they're saying Norville here but why and
they made Shaggy black okay look I I
don't honestly don't care but I have a
point to be made if they were going to
choose any character to be black I find
it funny that they chose the stoner
Munchies guy who is considered a coward
and I that to me is like why not Fred
that Fred is like the the strong leader
why would they I think it's racist the
progressives always end up being racist
in the end it's yeah no I I honestly I
just think it's really dumb what's on
his head it's his hairy did not have
that kind of hair it's not Shaggy I
don't yeah no longer couldn't they have
given him just like
hair like Shaggy I guess why did they
make I don't I don't understand they
gave the Asian the red hair
it's just it's just it look guys Fred
look like an idiot it's not Scooby-Doo
it is going to be the idiot I think they
even made Velma fat like not not like
fat fat but you know they made her like
chubby with a little bit yeah yeah a
little little fupa and chubby and just
real cringe and the trailer for this is
her basically saying that uh you can
never change she's doing a joke where
she's like you can never change things
and uh it's like everything always has
to stay the same and then she said
something like well at least the
character's still white and then it
reveals that Velma is now black or
whatever this is cultural stagnation
this is this is the death of art and
culture they can't make up new ideas
they've got no new ideas left yo it's
been 50 years Scooby it's come on yeah
and The Simpsons did you guys see The
Simpsons where Abe is gay
it's like it's like he's bi-curious or
whatever and I don't know and then
there's another Simpsons episode where
Bart gets mad that they gender swap
Itchy and Scratchy and so then feminists
like make fun of him or something like I
don't this is
guys so why do you think they're doing
this why why do you think that this is I
mean they're doing this with everything
everything no I think I think there's
some 80 year old white executive who
typed in you know Scooby-Doo into an AI
script writer and then it just spat out
some garbage and then went run with it
and that's it it's it's a kind of a
marketing Ploy too like I mean No One's
Gonna no one cares about a new
Scooby-Doo show I mean who but look at
us we're talking about it now this is
crazy it's because people are permanent
children yeah like dude I watched
Scooby-Doo when I was at really little
and it was okay and then when I go got
older I was like this is really dumb and
then I liked things like X-Men you know
when I was real Littles like Power
Rangers was fun but then after like the
first season or whatever I was like I
outgrew it and I was like eight and I'm
like I'm too cool for Power Rangers
Scooby-Doo was just not it it was the
same story every single time we get it
some dudes trying to lower property
values so he pretends to be Frankenstein
them making a new show that's aimed at
adults using these characters and then
race swapping them is just like we are
desperate we don't know what we're doing
we're gonna try and do Ghostbusters 2016
all over again is Scooby in this show
they don't even show Scooby there's no
Scooby Scooby is now a cat he's gonna be
a furry Japanese going to be a furry I'm
calling it right now they made Daphne
Asian
okay a red-headed Asian right-headed
Asian I don't see many redheads no man
it's an alternate universe this is the
most disappointing to me because he's
supposed to be a strong leader
he was supposed to be a football star
right I don't know he's like six three
and muscular yeah but now he's like
super skinny super soy
yeah yeah confused he's he's usually on
his face holding Shaggy back from the
brink that's like his main function it's
like hey everybody remember we have a
mission I I think
you made him Unstoppable
I love the Super Saiyan Shaggy memes
though that really is funny so have you
guys seen that video game multiverses
it got a lot of attention it's like
Warner Brothers Smash Brothers yeah I
got a lot of attention because velma's
super super move is to call the cops on
you but I I will admit when I was
watching the trailer for the game I'm
like oh so Warner Brothers is putting
other characters to a fighting game I'm
like this sounds dumb and it's like
Batman was there and then also Shaggy
shows up and I think it's funny I'm like
ah Shaggy fighting and then someone like
knocks a sandwich out of his hand and
then he goes Super Saiyan and I started
busting out laughing I'm like okay
that's that that's good I approve it is
funny Shaggy going Super Saiyan so so
you know but uh but this kind of takes
away from that because I don't know who
this guy Norville guy is and I don't
know why they're taken away from
Shaggy's an iconic character he's like
the Scooby-Doo character and there's a
show called like Orville that that Seth
MacFarlane show it's called Orville and
now they just call it Norville like yeah
Fred Fred's also demasculated he's going
to be a low IQ idiot who's going to be
making a bunch of mistakes he's going to
be the dope and he's going to be the
loser just like every guy who looks like
him is portrayed on television how
amazing would it be if Fred is no longer
the leader Norville is and every time
something bad happens Fred's like I'm
sorry guys that was my fault or it's
like the Scooby's arms he constantly
does things where he has to check his
own privilege yeah he'll be like let's
see who's really under that mask and
they'll be like don't pull off that mask
it's a cultural symbol geez Fred
colonize her much he goes I'm so sorry
guys I'm so sorry I'm wondering now
sorry guys if Scooby-Doo is like a
stoner show back in the day because
Scooby and Shaggy were high as hell most
of the show like [ __ ] he's talking to a
dog
machine yeah absolutely I never I never
understood as a kid and then I remember
what like when I finally got old enough
and I was like like you know and I was
told you realize the whole gag is that
they're stoned out of their mind Scooby
Snacks are Edibles for sure
Adam no I think he's just eating I think
he's eating dog food that's what we
that's what we got the money
Scooby Snacks dude they make scooby go
yeah they make they make them get like
crazy powerful the Scooby Snacks would
make them get like high you know they'd
make him kind of super crazy there's
definitely drugs this meme crosses the
line you've made Unstoppable
biggest buff of all time if they can
overcome the poor theme here and the
writing is actually decent it looks like
they've got I mean Mindy kaling's I
think she's a fantastic actor so maybe
she can pull like this this was a little
the writing was kind of bad we watched
this trailer
and she's kind of phoning in the
dialogue hold on hold on guys she's
talking like this wait wait hold on hold
on she's dead watch there's the guy he's
got a knife she screams and then maybe
she kills him you don't know oh she
kills him yeah there's a Twist
what does it say what is scoob
it says Dinkley is crossed that it says
what is scoob oh it's like is there it's
it's the show's called Velma so maybe
there's no Scooby in it like they're
looking for Scoops maybe they haven't
found Scooby yet and he's this is the
prequel she's missing yeah you know what
they should do these characters all get
killed and then the real ones find their
clothes they need to make into the
Shaggy verse and it's like all the
different shaggies from different
realities team up yeah give them awful
ideas please
have you guys seen The Knight violent
Night trailer oh Santa yeah oh I've seen
that one that looks pretty interesting
it's it's yeah you're right it's like
literal Die Hard with Santa I think it
looks like the best movie of Our
Generation and I'm proposing that we do
a company-wide outing at three on the
Thursday preview to go watch it so it's
uh who's at David Harbor and he's Santa
and it's just masterfully done at least
the trailer John leguizamo's in it yeah
and uh you know these their politics are
no good but their movie it looks really
great they disappointingly made Santa
white though so that's oh no I was kind
of into it until he punched into the
Santa sack in a in like a present shot
out at him
he has a knife and he stabs and it goes
into the sack and then he pulls out oh
it's got his present on the night that's
cool so basically like Santa's doing his
rounds and he's like half glazed over
just like I don't know and then he
stumbles upon an active Heist on
Christmas and then he's like I don't
want any trouble and then he basically
uses his Santa powers to take on a bunch
of terrorists in a big house and I just
it just looks hilarious what like the
puns he's like it's time for a season's
beating
it's horrible I know it's so good and
then he shoved the grenade where the sun
doesn't shine did you see that one yeah
and it runs away he's like wait I gotta
see this one I'm excited for that this
could be a problem though because he's a
son I mean Stan is kind of essentially a
god like how are they gonna give him an
enemy that's gonna put him in any real
danger does is there is there like an
anti-santa out there it's like in the
trailer just teleporting he can teleport
if there's a chimney nearby or something
yeah like how are they going to make him
uh like a you know I don't know I mean I
I just think it's going to be funny now
look look it is it is hard to come up
with new ideas because Futurama did the
robo Santa trying to kill everybody
which is not the same thing and there's
another movie I forgot what it's called
it's from like the 70s or whatever where
there's a guy just like Santa going
around killing people but this is
literally Santa Claus himself
inadvertently stumbling upon a die-hard
style kidnapping Heist because they this
Rich family's got a vault full of money
or whatever I think it looks hilarious
so I'm into it you know remember what
was that movie Jack Frost the snowman
that was killing everybody yeah yeah
yeah I never saw that they're doing that
with Winnie the Pooh too right like are
they making a oh yeah blood and honey
it's got a lot of potential so it is all
derivative pretty soon we're gonna have
like a Peppa Pig or a Bluey that goes
around murdering people Peppa Pigs
Revenge yeah I think when I write music
I basically take pieces from a bunch of
different songs I've heard in the past
and then put them all together into a
new song where you don't know that those
pieces like where they're from so it's
I'm definitely we're standing on the
shoulders of giants that's it's all
mashups yeah everything we do is a
language even is a mashup of what came
before but you got to be so intricate
with it that people don't know you're
using past material right like I came up
with a show idea called doobie moo and
it's about a gang of young people that
fight crime with a pet alligator with a
pet cow named doobie oh it's a cow it's
a cow now and uh it's a it's a cow
it's an original idea completely
original
and the uh the main characters are um
red yes and um braffney they eat
mushroom snacks and and Velma the
mushrooms that grow on doobies too and
baggies
special snacks man it really is crazy
how they just like
rehash old things non-stop over and over
and over again like we're on Fast and
the Furious 10. you know they've got to
use new tech new technology I think if
you want to make new art you've got an
integrate like modern tech did you
notice when the cell phones appeared it
took them like six years before they
started making cell phones and movies
because it was so cool to have a hero
that didn't have access to the outside
world couldn't resolve as he didn't know
was going on that's the big part of
movies is you don't know so as soon as
cell phones are invented it like erases
the drama of so many movies not not only
that but you'll notice in modern movies
they'll have the cell phone to their ear
and then someone will say something like
I am coming for your family and then you
hear a click and I'm like that doesn't
happen on cell phones yeah yeah that was
like and the crazy thing is do young
people even understand that there was a
a meme that is probably not real but
it's funny where some guy was holding up
a floppy disk and he was like kid in my
school just said why did you 3D print
the save icon
I saw that yeah I have no idea well I
don't know that's real but you know yeah
they have no idea like they've not used
these things what a weird
turn of events for our world what the
internet has done you know what I mean
we're very fortunate to have kind of
seen both sides of it we grew up kind of
before the internet we got to see it
come and into being and now our kids
just don't they don't know a world
without it what's that going to be like
you know I don't know I mean instant
gratification all the time my uh like my
entire life we've had TV is is
ubiquitous my parents were saying that
it was like when they were younger they
didn't have TVs in their Apartments
because they were expensive and they
didn't care that much
you know now it's like flat screen TVs
are in every room because they're Dirt
Cheap maybe that's because they want to
spy on us though for sure it's
manipulation like the power and control
of a government or people have over
people with the TV if you can get it I
don't know but wasn't there a story that
like TVs have microphones and cameras
spying on you uh yeah that's I think we
went on a search for for ones that
didn't
um and we were going around the specific
stores and there was like one left I was
able to finally grab it and okay by
myself I have no camera no microphone
have you seen that uh that cost chart
there's a there's a chart going around
the internet that tracks the cost of
everything going back to the 50s and and
how prices have rised for food Health
Care cars houses literally everything
like 100 things on this chart the only
thing that has gone down is TVs yeah
it's like just a bunch of stuff going up
and then you have TVs it's the only
thing that is decreased well they also
track what you watch they also have a
lot of data on you your personal
information on there so you know that
this is why a lot of the TVs are so
cheap is because they collect a lot of
data on you and then they sell that data
ah geez if you get people to watch the
news MSNBC you have control their minds
like do you find at Babylon B that you
guys create news do you feel like you're
creating new Concepts on here because a
lot of it's parody which is like using
an idea and then twisting it hold on let
me just interject you're wrong Ian it's
not parody it's it's prophesizing for us
can you tell us all the jokes that went
too far that you guys never published oh
my God but maybe we could do this maybe
on the members yeah like what's the
difference between parody and satire
here
um
I mean parody I feel like kind of um
is kind of aping off an off an existing
thing you know you have a you know you
you have a movie The Godfather and then
you have you know Mafia Mel Brooks Mafia
that there's a kind of a parody of that
um satire is exaggerating reality
um you know I think a lot of what makes
uh
our satire seem prophetic sometimes as I
think it's just the fact that it's
there's nothing complicated about it so
we I think we know the left better than
they know themselves a lot of times if
you if you know someone's world view
um and then you also combine that with a
knowledge of human nature you know if
you have a solid truthful worldview it's
not hard to predict what people are
going to do what people are going to say
that and the Babylon bee has a vat full
of a fluid with three precogs floating
in it and then wooden balls carve out
you know the future and then they say
hey that's funny let's write that up
it's actually a seeing Stone but yeah
Babylon B Staffing on robes and they all
stand in a big circle holding hands and
then the crystal lights up and they can
see the feature that's right yeah yeah
and the future is funny it's very fun
it's hard though I mean yeah we get a
lot of I mean feedback all the time
um please stop please stop because
you're giving them ideas sometimes I
feel like we're giving them I mean did
you see the one recently
um we did a and it was just a throwaway
joke I mean it's we call it the one joke
of the Babylon B it's like an identity
defies as joke you know blank identifies
as blank so he can blank
um and it was a it was a like Eminem's
uh introduces new uh purple trans m m
that identified as a Skittle yeah and uh
and they rolled out a purple lemonade
but yeah yeah a few months ago a few
weeks ago yeah uh to as a celebration of
like inclusivity and and diversity or
something like that they have a new
purple m m so just stuff like that I
think we have like 80 close to 80
prophecies the Black Mirror that TV show
Black Mirror that you think I stopped
making them because he was like I think
I'm giving them ideas or whatever he
felt like I mean that show is just like
bleeding edge just like
where they're hunting down the roaches
these these this humanoid yes monster
thing and they're like but they've got
like AR brain chips they're like
augmented in the neural net and so they
see the the roaches they kill them then
one guy gets like knocked out of the net
by this thing and he realizes that
they're actual humans that they've been
told are roaches because they have a
genetic deficiency and it's this weird
like
uh story of like genocide and and being
manipulated by machines you know Cloud
Schwab watched that episode and was like
I can't believe I did not think of that
so do you think that literally do you
think that you guys are giving ideas to
the war machine gosh dang I hope not I
hope not I wonder about that no I I no I
I think that uh human nature is what it
is a lot of things are inevitable
um you know and I I it's you're really
just kind of
you're you're watching the the the the
the
the
course that they're they're on and
you're just extrapolating it you know
all right we're gonna go to super chats
if you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share this show with your
friends and become a member at
timcast.com we're gonna have that
uncensored members only show coming up
at about 11 p.m you don't want to miss
it here we go we got Camilla mamani who
says yo Tim I heard in my Argentinian
news about undersea cables that Russia
could destroy could uh could destroy
them for breaking communication or
tapping them yes that is a current fear
energy cables all over the place I think
there's like New York to Brazil is one
of them crazy massive massive cables
if you're worried about the pipelines
getting hit they will they probably
won't destroy them what you need to
understand about Communications is that
in time of war and conflict people want
access to the information not to silence
it so I hear this a lot from activists
they'll be like the police are censoring
or the internet they're making it so we
can't share and live stream and I'm like
no they aren't it's the congestion the
police want you to share information so
they can intercept it and spy on you it
is bad that's why they bring in the
mobile cell tower trucks when there's
High congestion at protests depending on
when they do this sometimes they do it
because they want you to use your phone
and talk about your plans so they know
shutting you down would be bad for them
BC is me says yesterday I saw a 70 year
old lady walking her little dog wearing
an ultra Maga shirt made my day that
sounds fantastic
Grim Vale says do you have any plans to
ever do written fiction content on your
culture platforms trade publishing is
ultra woke and there aren't many
platforms where writers can just write
good stories without the gender stuff
forced in
yeah we were thinking about doing manga
or something graphic novels
um in the weekly release style but it's
a very very very difficult thing to do I
don't know if we would ever do like
fiction books or anything like that
Salem publishing we published a novel
through Salem a fantasy novel and and
got no pushback on any of the content
from them at all what's the novel uh the
postmodern Pilgrim's Progress is kind of
like a Multiverse hopping you know
allegorical tale uh me and Kyle wrote it
um but they're I mean they're the only
one I know of as far as publishing
houses go they're the only one I know of
that will really just let you write
anything you go anywhere else
um you're going to have very strict uh
parameters for what you can have in
there what you can't have in there you
know all the woke stuff so it's yeah
publishing business is kind of a mess
right now all right Heron gaming news
says did you hear Chicago held Slipknot
at gunpoint do you mean that Slipknot
was held at gunpoint in Chicago or the
band Chicago had a beef with the band
Slipknot and they held him at gunpoint I
know because that's what it sounds like
at first and I'm like I don't know if
that would be a thing like Slipknot it's
in Chicago fairly old yeah yeah Slipknot
they're they're still at it huh yeah and
they're man huge I didn't I didn't know
this you know that's the thing like very
very Chicago Police held Slipknot at
gunpoint thinking they were a
this is from this is from two days ago
from Barstool Sports thinking they were
about to rob a jewelry store oh wow
we're up there in full makeup the
Chicago Police still work yeah they
still do stuff
all right grafty says Bach the buck
button yes please but this was a 1999
that they this happened 1999 this was 20
30 years ago Clayton Johnson says
nothing like an EMP to send us back to
fighting with sticks and stones
eliminate the enemy without the nuclear
winter weapons of the future if an EMP
let's say let's say the big solar flare
blasts the Earth Mass one or how about I
got a better one let's say aliens come
here and then as punishment for
teetering on nuclear war they EMP the
planet destroying All Electronics how
long would it be until we just make new
ones
16 days until things are back to normal
if we don't have outside interference
can we restart the electrical grid is
the question
I don't know it depends on the power of
the EMP blast I think you can either fry
an electronic or just shut it down for a
short period of time but I don't know
enough about the mechanics if the
electrical grid was shuttered there'd be
billions dead within months a couple
months billions they must have a backup
ready to go
maybe something ready to like I'd
actually be more inclined to believe
they have underground bunkers ready to
go for themselves than anyone else and
like power lines underground connecting
deep underground Faraday cage barriers
and things like that to keep out the
the awful underground generators and
stuff that we don't know exactly I think
water is probably better right like
water is a better protection against uh
radiation
so like you could do a faraday cage and
then you can do an aquarium and then you
can seal your electronics in plastic and
then put them in the water
nice yeah water there was a story I read
about a scuba diver got sucked into an
intake valve in a nuclear plant was
swimming around in the reactor and
you're fine because the water blocks the
radiation you can't you know well yep
Shane Templeton says Joel salatin needs
to be a guest on here huge knowledge in
the natural way of raising chickens and
he has a very interesting take on
government programs regarding Farms
would love to see he and Luke have a
back and forth cool you know him don't
you know Joel I'm not sure okay he's
great he's a farmer naturalist I mean he
talks about getting in in the pig feces
with the pig while he's working and it's
better for how it's better for his
immune system he was very vocal during
the covid epidemic or pandemic whatever
you want to call it
Michelle Grimm says it's official the
end of an age no one has come up with an
original movie idea since the 90s I
swear let's make Speedy into Jose Owens
next and make him black just kidding
yeah I think about this when I think
about Groundhog Day
like that was an original concept wasn't
it like the day looping was the first
now there's like 800 movies that have
done this stay Loops yeah day Loops yeah
I like Napoleon Dynamite in the 40 year
old virgin I thought that was good 2007
I think six
yeah those were good just like rom-com
Groundhog Day though even though it kind
of had that original conceit it was a
it's a it was a very traditional story
it follows the kind of the hero's
journey beat for beat you know same
thing you see in Star Wars and all that
all that oh yeah Peterson was talking
about Jordan Peterson talks about like
tropes and um there's only so many
stories that can be told and we tell
like I don't know 17 stories and just
making it up off the top of my head but
like the hero's journey is one I no
that's not true you can make up more
than that they just wouldn't be
enjoyable like we wouldn't care about
them we wouldn't connect with them yeah
a story about a guy who gives up
everything
to buy scratchers
that's it inspiring that's and then he
wins and then uh he comes back oh that's
actually a good idea a dad who leaves
his kid to go get scratchers and then
like 10 years goes by and the kids like
Dad never came back and then one day he
does and he's a millionaire and he's
like I finally won and I'm back son I've
been scratching for decades and his
fingers are like his fingertips or
callous I did this for you son for you
in the kitchen and the kid was dying of
cancer and the dad came back just in
time to pay for his treatment
and then the dad has a heart attack and
then the kid like the dad actually know
he's got um I guess it wouldn't be
mesothelioma but it would be some kind
of lung damage from inhaling all of that
shredded scratcher particle and then the
kid no the dad loses that's what it is
but then the kid sues the the lottery
for the scratchers killing his dad and
then ends up getting 100 million dollars
that would be a that would be a funny
show that's what story is that that's
not the hero's journey or is it that's a
tragedy that's like Breaking Bad what
what Walter White did with uh meth he's
doing with scratch-offs right yeah it's
a tragedy but is it like for your son
yeah it's a yeah he sacrific he did
something Noble for Noble reasons but
but he went about it the wrong way and
ends up doing the opposite of what he
destroys his life destroys his son like
Thanos yeah
all right Triton 54 says on behalf of
all South Carolina residents I'd like to
apologize to all Tim cast listeners for
Lindsey Graham he should be removed
arrested and tried he I love Lindsey
Graham it's funny I love him he
represents no one he's anomalous like
even Nancy Pelosi has support from
Democrats Republicans don't like Lindsey
Graham Democrats don't like Lindsey
Graham what's he doing he's banging the
war drum Solinski said we need preamp
the strikes I immediately thought of
Lindsey Graham sounds like something
Lindsay would have said yo here's a good
one Alexander cresanti says I am
deploying down to Antarctica on Saturday
for four months providing food service
at McMurdo we'll miss listening to your
show also watch New York's midterms
there's a lot of support for zeldon
Upstate should be close you don't got
internet down to McMurdo they have
starlink down there now do they yeah he
should be able to get you need a star
link yes and unfortunately starlink is
cell locked so they only work with
specific satellites so like the star
link that I have won't work anywhere
else yeah it works within like a 500
mile range of the area oh no no no
actually though the new starlink RV
works everywhere yep so if you're going
down there get starlink RV maybe you can
still watch the show yeah that'd be cool
at the very least you can listen to it
you got phones down there right someone
can just call you and then press play
and leave their phone and you can smoke
signals that's why we're going to be
talking about in the future soon smoke
signal Morse code for every single word
said it'll only take three weeks to give
you the full show just make sure you
bring your flamethrower in case anything
gets thawed from the ice that should
never have been Adrian Contreras says
seven dollars and nine cents a gallon at
the gas station in Hollywood yesterday
thank God my company pays for gas also
Shaggy was named Norville in a show
called Pup Named Scooby-Doo Scooby's
real name is scubert the more you know
best name ever scubert yeah I'll lay off
the Norville Orville references then
Norville
ryzen tactic says Whitmer killed the
elderly moderates in Michigan need to
understand that they can vote for
abortion and vote for Dixon Article 2
Section 9 paragraph 5 of the Michigan
Constitution prevents Governors from
vetoing ballot proposals
interesting
free men Die free says quote we need a
vast military-style campaign Prince
Charles to the world economic Forum the
Russia Ukraine conflict is intentional
to promote the great reset I don't know
that's a bold thing I mean Putin was on
like a world economic Forum website
wasn't he and then he got removed yeah
hmm
why here's a question why wouldn't world
leaders be in on it why wouldn't all
world leaders just hang out and be like
we're the best we're the most powerful
we're in charge why go to why fight with
anybody
why I don't know
it's a good question it's like they're
vying for position one two and three
they want pole position in the New World
Order
I don't know man Putin's like the
richest guy in the planet
wouldn't you just be like I'm rich
unless it's ideological and he's like my
people will not be subjugated you know
I think there's probably is a little bit
of that
it's not our political yeah
what do we got we got some super jets
pork chopolis great name says I just
hope World War III holds off until after
the Super Mario movie drops in April is
that an April priorities
what's uh when's wakanda forever coming
out is that this November
sure
I do I will say uh
She-Hulk today
I give a
C plus oh better really well Daredevils
in it and and uh Daredevil's a great
character and I knew they were gonna
they were gonna Rob us of the scene we
needed so spoilers I guess
there's a scene where Daredevil is like
gonna fight some dudes
and uh it's been years since the Netflix
show Daredevil and we got to see that
amazing uncut fight sequence in the
hallway and so then a bunch of dudes
running and I'm like oh this is it I
know what's gonna happen you think
you're gonna get an epic fight with with
Daredevil but she-hulk's just gonna one
shot and then sure enough he like gets
ready and he like pulls out his weapons
and then all of a sudden the ceiling
collapses and then she hooks like and
I'm like
yeah but it was but it was it was it was
good it was good enough and I think it
was mostly good because I I'm watching
Daredevil and I like I like you know the
Daredevil show and the character and
everything
other than that Shield has been pretty
bad pretty bad
all right DD Mega doodoo says aside from
not getting a notification had a hard
time uh hard trying to watch this on my
TV the suggested vids were defaulted and
had to type out the channel name
completely must be a good topic yes yes
indeed I think I think the reason
YouTube's censoring us is because the
The Shaggy story
they were like how dare you yeah yeah
that's a touch if you Google search
Velma it Reigns Pride Flags yeah
yeah that's weird
well all right Velma Dinkley Velma
Dinkley
Joseph says simmer down boys all they
say is 40 chess what does that mean
no no sick commode oh Dragon says
Brick's partnership includes Russia and
China she has more interest in Russia
than the Ukraine also Russia won't use
nukes they'll win without them
Maybe
Maybe
Lance link says Bush use tactical nukes
in Iraq and no one ever said a thing I
don't know if that's true I think the
only time nukes have ever been used is
uh Japan they're about depleted uranium
Weaponry because they make tank armor
out of depleted uranium it was so strong
that you needed to make bullets out of
depleted uranium and Pierce the armor
and then they'd shoot it and they would
go into the dirt and just irradiate the
soil around there it's still there
radiating people and things yeah Gulf
War syndrome a lot of people have it so
those are tactical nukes
no no not not really I mean tactical
nuclear weapons I don't know how you
would
oh gee lesbian says Hunter Biden the
real savior of freedom and the USA
well who knew well there you go there's
a Twist leaking all this information
what do we got here Rick Barley says how
you all feel about House of the dragon
and rings of power I feel the first
house of the Dragon shows uh how to have
a diverse cast while remaining faithful
I immediately stopped watching it when
they time jumped 10 years because if I'm
going to invest in a show because I want
to learn the story of a set of
characters and then you just end that
whole story arc and then start a new one
I'm out it's like I I man it it's it's
it I feel like I'm watching the wrong
show I'm like what happened
there was a conflict dude collapses
right King what's his face drops to the
ground you're like whoa and then the
next episode
10 years later you're like huh I heard
from a lot of people it was pretty
jarring tons of people announced they
dropped the show because of it I did
articles I liked watching it but I like
being a contrarian and and I like weird
stuff and yeah it's it's totally
different it totally catches you off
guard I kind of like that I I like you
know
It's Better Call Saul is one of the best
I've ever seen
from start to finish you can see how
they subtly and very slowly change the
characters and how the stories evolve
and the the motivations are very
satisfying like you never get some weird
Revenge of the Sith moment where all of
a sudden you know main character Jimmy
McGill becomes Saul he doesn't just go
like I'm gonna be evil now it's like no
there's like a Content attempt at like
sort of doing the right thing and it's
like a slow transition I'm like this is
great I heard it was brilliant what I
want to know is how what on Earth
happened between it because the rings of
power one of their main writers was the
writer for better Carl Saul one of them
yeah so like I couldn't even watch 15
minutes I was just like what happened
like what happened between Better Call
Saul and rings of power like for that
that quality they talk about it they've
been watching every episode on pop
culture crisis and they've it looks like
they're trying to mimic the way that
Tolkien wrote his flowery language but
they're not writing it like they're just
creating like comes across like grade
school philosophy just like trying to
sound really profound but it's just
silly yeah and then people get bored not
are confused and then they have so many
characters that they're like showing you
a little bit from these characters you
don't know who they are careful about
them because you don't know who they are
and then there's just too many
characters too many story lines kind of
like the last season of Game of Thrones
yeah that was a mess
yeah there's nowhere for for Game of
Thrones to go because that it was it's
kind of a nihilist story so there's
there's no there's no Redemptive Arc to
it they should have brought Ned Stark
back the Red Witch should have
resurrected him and he reunited him with
his family I thought that would have
been awesome yeah yeah or you know
George RR Martin can finish writing the
books man that show just went off a
cliff
everybody was watching and talking about
awesome it was and I was like I don't
care and then one day I think I was on a
plane to New Zealand and uh it's a long
flight so they had like seven episodes
of season four I think it was I can't
remember and I started watching it I was
like this is really good I need to stop
watching it so I can start from the
beginning and then I bin binged watched
from season one and then
man did that shall fall off a cliff as
soon as they got away from the books
because they had no idea what they're
doing yet same with token too you know
they they thought they could write a
show based on tolkien's work with no
Source material
um except these appendices the Tolkien
wrote and it just does not work does not
work at all
John Gagner says I no longer get
notifications from timcast IRL Matt
Walsh Stephen Crowder Blair white or Joe
Rogan the war for your mind is real you
must be the notifications you want to
see in this world
if YouTube isn't sending them out then
you need to take the videos and post
them
um if you'd like to help us it's the
only way to overcome that attempt at
Shadow Banning is to just push through
with the Grassroots effort that and
we're buying ads in Times Square the
entire North Tower for uh uh on New
Year's and it's going to be hilarious
and you know when people are watching
CNN they're going to see it in the
background it's going to be amazing yeah
we talked about on the Babylon to be
doing something like that like in in
California putting putting up some
Billboards like on Gavin newsom's drive
from from his home to work
um you know like Satan approves Gavin
newsom's new abortion policy and have a
picture of the devil up there or
something just like have like one
billboard after another knowing that
he's going to drive by them all
I think that was inspired by you a
little bit because you were like the
Taylor Lorenz thing what's that the
Taylor Lorenz thing yeah yeah yeah yeah
I just I tweeted kind of as I don't
remember why I was thinking that I was
like do I gotta buy a billboard in Times
Square saying that she did this so that
people like you know get it and then
Jeremy boring at the daily wire was like
I'm I'm down I'll I'll get in on this
and then we did and then they they went
nuts over there I love stunts like that
that's great yeah and then I was just
like
I wonder why there are so many more
people who have way more money than I do
who don't try to just
push back on this culture and they just
don't care and because they're rich
[ __ ] they don't want to I don't know
man it's like Risk a lot of people are
risk averse that's someone's saying when
they have kids do people have kids you
get more conservative too what do they
do like I was watching Trevor no quits
right and I read that his salary was 16
million dollars per year and I'm like
homeboy's getting more than a million
bucks a month what does he do with all
that money like at a certain point
you're just like I have too much money
does he just like give it to needy kids
because you don't see it now I'm not
saying I'm not trying to rag on Trevor
Noah for that I'm just saying like very
very wealthy people and you never see so
what do they do do they just like give
it to a wealth manager and say figure it
out I guess that seems just so boring
lame yeah I mean what this idea that
your money has to make money and I mean
if you're that rich you don't need more
money I I don't see why you wouldn't
dump it into things that create cultural
capital you know it's rewarding to see
the culture move you know what I mean
don't people want to invest in movies
invest in TV shows unfortunately a lot
of people very very rich people do
called impact investment you know
billionaires if it's all leftists yeah
there's like Peter thiel's doing some
stuff but man I gotta tell you if I had
one billion dollars let alone 5 to 20
I'd be funding crazy stuff boys
you know what I would do if I had a
billion dollars I would set up a table
I would get obviously security guards
and then I'd let people line up outside
and come in one at a time with their
proposals and I'd just be writing checks
I'd be like Shark Tank you should do it
not even like should be funny I just be
like what's your idea and the guy's like
I want to open a bacon store what's that
it sells bacon anything up just bacon
done how much do you need there you go
have a nice day
the company it's an investment yeah but
like roll with it man just do fun stuff
why not I would put money in I would
like hire a bunch of people and be like
let's make a graphic novel publishing
arm you know so we're trying to do this
stuff obviously but I just it's I wish I
made a fraction of the money some of
these guys make but what do they do with
it all especially the ones who complain
about the culture war and are concerned
about Free Speech I'm like bro you got a
billion dollars you could you could fart
and impact media Jeff Bezos bought the
Washington Post yep we don't got it come
on man and not only that but there's
there's people are starving for that
people are starving for good stories
because they're they just don't exist I
was talking about how I wanted to open a
cafe uh and then open it up next to
Starbucks and then do like a really
great Co-op deal where we just like pay
the staff really really well and then
convince everyone to quit Starbucks and
come work for us we will be not woke and
we will pay way better than all these
Mega corporations because our end goal
won't be to just generate massive
profits for the shareholders it will be
to push back on the culture and and and
make a statement to all these companies
that want to engage in this weird
cult-like woke Behavior we will make a
competitive market Opera option where
people won't want to work for you and
won't want to buy from you but I can't
do that right now because that requires
a lot of money so
where where are the the the mega wealthy
like Trump could do this yeah you know
Trump could but he did start the truth
social he made truth social sure but he
took a lot of donations and hasn't
really done much with it that's just so
weird to me I don't know that's just me
maybe I'm crazy
um we had some of the shows that that uh
you know power likes to be hidden and
I'm like that's that's really it people
don't want anyone to know that they and
I I totally get it yeah that was Tucker
Max that was a good conversation because
there are people I got to tell you when
people find out you're successful they
crawl out of the woodwork yeah I
couldn't imagine what it must be like
for someone who wins the lottery I read
a story about a dude in India who won
the lottery and then people started like
harassing him and like targeting his
family demanding money just crazy stuff
dude I watched a Mr Beast video where
they did that thing where it's like you
gotta put your hand in the million
dollars and whoever if whoever's the
last person wins it and then guys like I
promise 50 Grand to this person that
person I'm like dude you're gonna get a
phone call from every single person
you've ever met talking about how you're
their best friend and they always
believed in you and now they need 50
Grand yeah that's the way it works man
messes up your life
but that's why people try to keep it a
secret that's why like a lot of people
they win the lottery they don't want
anyone to know that's why that's
probably why a lot of these you know
Wildlife individuals don't buy
Billboards in Times Square they don't
want to make themselves you know the
center of attention or anything like
that so they could Finance someone else
that pushes the same I know messages and
morals through through a foundation they
start and give money to there is that
one that I'm thinking we got George
Soros doing this like crazy you got
Mackenzie Bezos and Jeff Bezos both
doing Bill Gates Bill Gates where is
anybody else have you heard of the
you've seen you've probably seen the
Billboards the values pass it on
like you know courage pass it on you
know uh oh yeah thankfulness pass it on
and it just it's just a billboard it has
a character quality and maybe like an
inspiring figure that whole campaign is
just financed by some like billionaire
who lives in Colorado that's nice that
just like I want to make the I want to
make the world better and I want to make
people better so they just they just
purchase Billboards everywhere very I
don't I don't know if it uh it's moving
the needle at all but it's there's
another example of it I think Billboards
aren't particularly effective the thing
about Times Square is it has it has it
has a a decent amount of uh a decent
effect and it was kind of just to make a
statement like we can do this gets
people talking about it well you know
yeah it's it's that we have come to the
point of success where we rival you you
are not the elites anymore we are here
and that's why we decided against doing
any hard political messaging that was
like directly attacking the
establishment what we you know the most
the closest we get to is Michael Mouse's
quote on the Times Square billboard
saying
uh the corporate press gave you the
narrative Tim Cass gives you the news
and we talked about it and it's like if
you create an ad that insults The
Establishment you are setting yourself
apart and telling regular people you are
not a part of a part of the machine
you're you are not rivaling them if you
just put your ads up there you're just
sitting there next to Coca-Cola and
Eminem people are going to associate you
with you know dominant culture and
that's the goal the goal is to just tell
people we are winning
we are here don't worry about it you're
gonna you're gonna hear more from us and
you do I mean you do feel that you you
feel that the dominant culture and this
Legacy Media I I watched a late night
comedy show last night for like the
first time in years because I was in a
hotel and that's you know there's
nothing else to watch it is so sad it
seems so it's just empty
um the laughs are not there anymore you
do get the sense that these these this
Legacy Media
um that ruled the airwaves for 50 60
years is really dying there's just
nothing left no one's watching this
stuff I got that with Colbert I don't
know which way oh my goodness yeah I
watched Colbert and I watched Seth
Meyers and it was just sad it was
politics yeah it was it was politics it
wasn't funny
um the guests weren't funny and I'm
wondering who's watching this stuff and
like Greg Gutfeld on Fox News is beating
them in the ratings you know and and
yeah there are YouTube channels that are
beating him in the ratings and and so
you really do get the sense that it's
well we get we're on their way out we
get uh
we were getting more views on our show
than Trevor Noah was getting on his show
yeah but he was getting more YouTube
views on the clips from his show than
our Clips got on this show so it was it
was interesting for like if you were to
compare this live show
to his granted I guess his show is
shorter so you can argue that you know
there's there's a way to argue he was
doing better I suppose and YouTube
probably promotes it too I mean oh that
that's the thing about him CNN and all
the they're just getting pushed pushed
up we're fighting against the censorship
they're getting actively promoted yeah
I'd rather listen let's grab uh we just
gotta grab uh one's house yeah like okay
one more Super Chat Mar um marked
ashamed says F in the chat for catalog
who is next Google is also pushing for
him to be disbarred Google is or or
people are well the story I've heard
this may not be anchored either is that
he uh people complain to the bar about
get trying to get him disbarred and then
he doxed them but it turns out according
to Jeremy the quartering he wasn't
actually doxing them he was displaying
Pub information that was already public
and then YouTube banned him for that and
this is unclear I don't know if that's
confirmed all right everybody if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
Channel and share the show with your
friends be the notification you want to
see in the world we're going to of a
members only uncensored show over at
timcast.com at about 11. you don't want
to miss it so become a member at timcast
you can follow the show at timcastirl
you can follow me at timcast Joel you
want to shout anything out
no uh I guess
um you know check out the Babylon bee
um same deal you know that we've been
censored on a lot of the the big Tech
platform so if you want to see our stuff
sign up for our email newsletter we'll
send our our daily news right to your
inbox and uh and you won't miss anything
where do people get the books uh the
books available anywhere Amazon or or
wherever books are sold so yeah thanks
for coming on that was great you guys do
great work so thank you so much my
YouTube channel is youtube.com forward
slash we are change I have a lot of fun
there with Atlas today I did a video
about foreign policy musk and a lot of
other crazy things youtube.com forward
slash we are change hope to see you
there because follow me at Ian Crossland
uh YouTube Twitter Minds the list goes
on anywhere social media is found and
definitely check out cast Castle on
timcast.com it's excellent and if you
haven't seen the entire Arc you'll want
to start from episode one
let me know what you think in the
comments I want to hear I want some
feedback and we are going to have
comments back on now yeah oh okay cool
we got comments we were trying to get
Minds for a while and we couldn't figure
it out we'll eventually start
integrating especially if Elon buys
Twitter man I see a big integration
process in the in the donning on the
horizon right on yep good stuff for sure
thank you guys all very much for tuning
in this evening thank you Jill for
coming you guys can follow me as always
on twitterminds.com at sour patchlitz as
well as Sarah patchlitz.me we will see
you all over at timcast.com thanks for
hanging out bye guys